[Music]
welcome to the huberman lab guest Series
where I and an expert guest discuss
science and science-based tools for
everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford School of Medicine today's
episode marks the sixth and final of the
six episode series on fitness exercise
and performance and today's discussion
is all about nutrition and
supplementation to maximize your fitness
exercise and performance goals Dr Andy
Galpin I'm super excited to discuss
today's topic which is nutrition and
supplementation for performance and
recovery and I'm particularly excited
about this conversation because I've
been interested in supplementation and
nutrition for performance really since
my teens but also because in recent
years we've witnessed a massive
transformation in the general public in
terms of their view of supplementation
and nutrition first of all more people
are thinking about nutrition
what is good nutrition what is not a
very barbed wire topic as you know but
there are some truths in there that
we'll discuss but also supplementation
you know whereas 10 15 years ago I think
most people um would either be really
into supplements that was a small
percentage of people but the majority of
people were either told or were thinking
oh you know vitamins you mostly excrete
them they're just expensive urine
nowadays it seems that many people
including many of my colleagues and
Physicians all the way down to sports
performance experts
are taking and making recommendations
about certain supplements and so the way
that I like to think about supplements
is that they aren't necessarily just
supplements which makes it sound like
they are augmenting what should already
be there but you're not quite getting
enough of but indeed a lot of these
things we call supplements are very
potent compounds that can transform our
ability to perform in the short term to
recover from exercise and that can
really shape brain chemistry hormone
patterns acutely and when taken long
term so I'm very excited about today's
topic and to be able to try and sort
through this let's call it a cloud
hopefully not a storm but this cloud of
supplements that are out there because
indeed many of them are excellent and
can provide us a lot
some of them are terrible
and then some just don't do anything and
therefore are terrible because either
they have side effects or because
they're very expensive and they don't do
anything and then of course within the
realm of nutrition there's an equal
amount of of confusion but
that's why I'm talking to you because
you're going to put Clarity and
structure and definition on these
incredibly important topics you you
absolutely nailed it there one of the
major reasons supplements can work is
because you can consume nutrients in
extremely high concentrations such that
you would not get in nature through food
having said that
you really do want to focus on the basic
sleep nutrition hydration and I'm going
to get into very specific detail later
with some of those things that said
there are plenty of situations and
circumstances when supplementation can
do exactly what you said
also though because you are taking them
in such high concentrations
they can also be unproductive they can
be destructive or they can be
counterproductive so in case if you're
taking a couple of supplements over here
it may actually be counteracting the
benefits of some of the other
supplements over there so in the ideal
situation we would be able to work like
snipers here so we would be able to run
full biological testing so extensive
blood work and saliva and urine and
stool and have an in-depth analysis of
your gut microbiome and your stress
patterns and your time of day and your
cortisol curve and like all the things
that we do in our high performance folks
with that then we can get extremely high
Precision supplementation and and quite
honestly our philosophy is we only give
individuals exactly what they need so
even some of the standard uh generally
safe and effective supplements we don't
really necessarily use them if there's
no specific need we've talked about the
consequences of this with things like
antioxidants but even simple stuff like
stimulants and other tools that are
effective for Recovery we don't use them
unless we have a reason
that said that's not the reality for a
lot of people they're not going to be
able to do something like that or
somebody who can help them in that so
there are a handful of supplements that
I would consider to be in my my 80 20
rule which is sort of like the 20 of
supplements that are going to give you
80 of the benefit for the lowest cost
and so what I can actually do is just
sort of start there even though this
like burns my skin and my soul a little
bit I absolutely hate this I am the
context guy I'm the it it depends it's
high Precision guy but let's be real um
there are a number of supplements that
are fairly effective and fairly cheap
for a wide range of outcomes so this is
for general public this is for
people who want to do the three buckets
right you want to look a certain way so
supplements that could enhance muscle
growth and fat loss
non-hormonal based supplements of course
supplements that can improve energy or
physical performance again from
everything from you know squatting more
to feeling better in your yoga class to
having more energy throughout the day to
our third major bucket that we've been
talking about throughout this entire
series which are longevity so we can
cover those first if you'd like to start
there yes absolutely let's start there
oftentimes when we think of supplements
we immediately jump to High Sport
performance type of things or vigorous
workouts or muscle building though that
doesn't necessarily have to be the case
take for example creatine and I've
spoken about this at lengthens with
Darren kandow who's done a tremendous
amount of research I was just up at his
lab recently in Canada and he has
covered extensively in fact I think I
put up a post perhaps I could draw this
up um
where he laid out all the Myriad of
benefits of creatine this is taken in
the you know typically three to five
grams per day of dose of creatine
monohydrate which has the most research
behind it seems to be extremely low side
effects
in almost anyone and the benefits
including course things like muscle
performance and strength and things like
that and if you go back to our
discussion and our episode on metabolism
and endurance we talked about the
phosphoryl creatine system so you can
figure out kind of what this is going to
do in terms of effect that said there's
excellent information and data coming
out and all on the benefits of bone
mineral density and creatine there's a
ton of work looking at a host of
cognitive factors from memory executive
function
to effects potentially on even things
like depression
mood to alzheimer's Parkinson's uh
all forms of neurodegenerative disease
in fact it's it's pretty obvious the
brain loves creatine as a fuel and so
not only we sort of discussed in the
episode as being the fuel for skeletal
muscle contraction but the brain needs
to do that as well the astrocytes are on
the brain need to be able to provide
energy Etc so it's very clear that
metabolism in the brain is reduced with
things like TBI and potentially
concussions so
um now to be extremely clear
creatine does not prevent any of those
diseases it does not treat any of them
and the data are mixed but it's more and
more are coming some show a little bit
of benefits I'm showing you know maybe
none but I'm not aware of any research
in those areas that show it has any
downside
for the most part side effects are
extremely minimal if not null and then
potentially some benefit and depending
on the specific study so we could put up
a if you'd like a couple of links
directly to those meta-analyzes and
folks can go through those things one by
one so
um I only say that to again maybe expand
our understanding or thinking about what
these types of supplements can do it's
not just about growing muscle
or you know high performance it's
everything to again there's an
association with recovery so creatine is
fantastic for recovery for muscle for
muscle damage it helps and can
potentially Aid in fat loss and a whole
host of things so you can actually also
even look at websites like examine.com I
have you know no affiliation with them
whatsoever but if you want to just type
in something like creatine monohydrate
you can see a whole list and you're
going to see thousands of studies of the
potential benefits of creatine so that
is is always number one on my list I'm
relieved to hear that creatine sits at
the top of your supplementation list
because well first of all I started
taking it when I was in college at that
time I was taking it in this kind of
loading mode where you take it in um you
know anywhere from uh 15 to 25 grams per
day often causing some gastric distress
often combining with fruit juice to try
and shuttle it into the muscles sure and
then so-called maintenance phase of
reducing to 10 or 15 grams per day now
days I just take about five grams or so
although later I know you're gonna tell
me why I should probably be taking more
than five grams per day given my body
weight so I know we'll get into some of
those specifics a little bit later but
in addition to experiencing Direct
effects on muscle size and strength
which I did I don't know how it
contributed to my cognitive function or
if it does now because there's really no
way to tease that out with with standard
at home tests like a scale but
it is very clear to me based on the
literature that you described and some
of which we've covered on other episodes
of the podcast that the phospho creatine
system is vitally important for
forebrain function right the forebrain
of course being the the portion of brain
broadly speaking the portion of brain
just behind your forehead that is
responsible for planning action setting
rules and context so even as simple as
if you're going downfield in a game of
soccer or basketball and you're on
offense and then uh you make an attempt
on goal or basket and then it switches
and you go back now you're on defense
that being on defense is very different
than being on offense and that goal
excuse me that that rule switching is a
prefrontal cortical function as is every
context dependent way of thinking or
acting and so anything that can favor
function of the forebrain I think is
good for uh humans in general it
suppresses anxiety allows us to
interpret what's going on for us and so
I'm very
um relieved and gratified to hear that
creatine sits at the top of the list
also as I'm sure you'll point out again
later creatine is for the most part a
relatively affordable supplement for
most people so here we're not talking
about something that's really esoteric
or that you have to you know fly to some
remote location to get an infusion of
right um but although I apologize to all
you because I know the price has
skyrocketed recently really yeah why is
that I think it's just well nobody knows
but it's quote unquote Supply and uh
demand issue if you will so those prices
have gone up there's also of course been
shipping problems in the world and
things so uh every time I talk about
creatine right now people just flame me
for like oh my God it's so expensive now
I'm like I know I'm sorry but honestly
it's only so expensive because you're
used to being so cheap
so when you when you counter the fact
that you're like right yeah like
relative to the other stuff you're
probably taking relative to any other
number of purchases
um for the it still lands very high in
my Roi List my you know my 80 20 because
of that it's
um it can be taken any time of the day
it doesn't have to be in magical
combination you talked about
co-ingesting with carbohydrates that can
enhance uh how quickly you can get into
the system in fact it's it's going to
work on the exact same mechanisms will
probably potentially talk about
hydration but these things are shuttled
so anytime you bring in carbohydrate
that's going to
be shipped into tissue as quickly as it
can creatine then goes along super ride
and then it brings water into the right
that's how you enhance hydration that's
why it's important to have carbohydrates
when you're trying to hydrate so you're
just going to take it in there and
that's also why you get quote-unquote
cell swelling which is a good thing like
you're it's just enhancing hydration we
actually use it a ton in our post way in
protocols so and individuals that have
to cut water weight creatine is a great
thing to throw back in there it's going
to help you rehydrate it's also why when
you take 30 grams of it it can pull a
bunch of fluid in the intestines and and
there you go with your little bit of GI
distress so
um yeah there's a lot of fun things you
can talk about there I just had to flag
that because every time I've been
talking about it recently and I say it's
cheap people are killing me for it so I
apologize I don't know how to make it
any cheaper but it's still fairly fairly
affordable yeah I would say relatively
inexpensive compared to a lot of
supplements out there and when thinking
about the return on investment is um
it's quite good yeah so like actually
sorry it started to cut you out but I
was also thinking there's been a number
of studies on sleep deprivation as well
with creatine that can help so obviously
sleep deprivation will generally reduce
cognitive function and creatine can
ameliorate some of that drop so if you
think about it in that context I had a
crummy night of sleep well and if that
enables you to perform a little bit
better in your job then you would make
up the dollar or so whatever you paid
for that day's supply of creatine so it
is something kind of on that note
it's not going to work as an acute
response so it's not something you're
like I feel terrible let me throw some
creatine Down the Hatch I'll feel better
that's not going to work it's going to
take several weeks to have a noticeable
effect it needs to be stored in tissue
it needs to be built up before you can
actually do much of anything so it is
unlike some of the other things like
stimulants or caffeine that have an
acute you know response right now
and so if you're going to take it you
probably need to consume it consistently
if you can't do that then really there's
no point in doing it and the loading
phase you mentioned distance were here
is something you can do again if you
need to enhance the storage of it really
quickly so say for example
we've done this in some military cases
where it's like you get back to base and
you've only got a week and you got to go
back out we may actually have to do a
little bit of a loading phase then but
if that's not the case the loading phase
is unnecessary it's not really harmful
other than maybe GI stress and maybe
waste but you're going to have three or
four weeks it's going to reach full
saturation plenty of time to to be there
in that if you're in that three to seven
grams per day range I'm glad you
mentioned the slow accumulating positive
effects of creatine as compared to
so-called acute effects because the way
that I think of Health promoting and
performance enhancing protocols like
viewing morning sunlight or
um endurance exercise for that matter or
creatine
or sleep for instance is that while they
can have effects in the immediate term
you might feel a little bit or in the
case of a good night's sleep a lot
better it's really the accumulative
effect of raising your Baseline level of
functioning you know there's another way
to think about it is
um these
supplements or behaviors and quality
nutrition when done consistently over
time and that doesn't mean 100 of the
time but you know because probably 80 of
the time sure
lead to a sort of uh buoyancy in your
system that allows you to be more
resilient under conditions where
conditions aren't perfect right and if
conditions are made perfect or close to
perfect and you already have that
buoyancy that's when you really start to
see the ultra high performance effects
um that are so much fun but they have to
be established through consistent
supplementation consistent nutritional
intake so today I know we're going to
distinguish between uh normally they're
called chronic and acute effects but
that makes it sound like chronic illness
the moment people hear chronic well they
might think of other things but but in
the context of Health they typically
think of you know chronic illness and
we're not talking about that what we're
talking about is slow modulatory effects
in the body a lot of things in the body
take time to build up but once they've
built up they they clearly can benefit
us and then other things as you
mentioned you know a stimulant for
instance has a very acute effect that
it's going to occur with you know Peak
within 30 minutes and wear off within
you know four hours or so can also have
some chronic effects but typically it's
a short-lived effect so we just want to
frame up the the language that we'll be
using and I'm really excited to dive
into this topic and I think creatine is
a beautiful example of a supplement that
has positive chronic mental and physical
benefits down the road I can come back
and talk a little bit more about
creatine and we can cover some other
information regarding best practices for
for getting the most out of it as well
as we'll certainly dive into some of the
common side effects or at least a
thought of side effects while we're here
though I also could throw in a few other
of these high impact low-cost generally
safe things that are my 80 20 rule if
you will so the way I actually kind of
think about it is you want one from each
of three categories and these categories
are fuel
stimulants
and fatigue blockers so creatine is
actually in the fuel it's not a
stimulant as we talked about The Chronic
effect there so we've already knocked
that one off another one from the
fatigue blocker
is going to be anything like beta
alanine or sodium bicarbonate and then
from the stimulant yeast of course we
have anything like a beetroot juice to a
caffeine or something of the equivalent
so we can come back again and talk about
all those in more detail a little bit
later before we begin I'd like to
emphasize that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research roles at
Stanford it is also separate from Dr
Andy galpin's teaching and research
roles at Cal State Fullerton it is
however part of our desire and effort to
bring zero cost to Consumer information
about science and science-related tools
to the general public in keeping with
that theme we'd like to thank the
sponsors of today's podcast our first
sponsor is momentous momentous makes
supplements of the absolute highest
quality the huberman Lab podcast is
proud to be partnering with momentous
for several important reasons first of
all as I mentioned their supplements are
of extremely high quality second of all
their supplements are generally in
single ingredient formulations if you're
going to develop a supplementation
protocol you're going to want to focus
mainly on using single ingredient
formulations with single ingredient
formulations you can devise the most
logical and effect active and
cost-effective supplementation regimen
for your goals in addition momentous
supplement ship internationally and this
is of course important because we
realize that many of the huberman Lab
podcast listeners reside outside the
United States if you'd like to try the
various supplements mentioned on the
huberman Lab podcast in particular
supplements for Hormone Health for Sleep
optimization for Focus as well as a
number of other things including
exercise recovery you can go to live
momentous spelled ous so that's live
momentous.com huberman today's episode
is also brought To Us by levels levels
is a program that lets you see how
different foods and activities affect
your health by giving you real-time
feedback on your blood glucose using a
continuous glucose monitor many people
are aware that their blood sugar that is
their blood glucose level is critical
for everything from Fat Loss to muscle
gain to healthy cognition and indeed
aging of the brain and body most people
do not know however how different foods
and different activities including
exercise or different temperature
environments impact their blood glucose
levels and yet blood glucose is
exquisitely sensitive to all of those
things I first started using levels
about a year ago as a way to understand
how different foods exercise and timing
of food relative to exercise and quality
of sleep at night impact my blood
glucose levels and I've learned a
tremendous amount from using levels it's
taught me when best to eat what best to
eat when best to exercise how best to
exercise and how to modulate my entire
schedule from work to exercise and even
my sleep so if you're interested in
learning more about levels and trying a
continuous glucose monitor yourself go
to levels.link huberman that's
levels.link huberman today's episode is
also brought To Us by element element is
an electrolyte drink that contains the
exact ratios of the electrolyte sodium
magnesium and potassium to optimize
cellular functioning for mental and
physical performance most people realize
that hydration is key we need to ingest
enough fluids in order to feel our best
and perform our best but what most
people do not realize is that the pro
upper functioning of our cells and nerve
cells neurons in particular requires
that sodium magnesium and potassium be
present in the correct ratios now of
course people with pre-hypertension and
hypertension need to be careful about
their sodium intake but what a lot of
people don't realize is that if you
drink caffeine if you exercise and in
particular if you're following a very
clean diet that is not a lot of
processed foods which of course is a
good thing chances are you're not
getting enough sodium potassium and
magnesium to optimize mental and
physical performance element contains a
science-backed ratio of 1 000 milligrams
that's one gram of sodium 200 milligrams
of potassium and 60 milligrams of
magnesium and no sugar if you'd like to
try element you can go to drink element
that's lmnt.com huberman to get a free
element sample pack with your purchase
again that's drink element lmnt.com
huberman to claim a free sample pack to
start off I want to ask you about
something that as soon as I say it some
people might roll their eyes or wonder
why are we even talking about that now
but that I have to believe is among the
more fundamental if not foundational
aspects of nutrition and supplementation
for performance and that's hydration
right I mean I think we hear hydration
it's like okay we have to drink six to
eight glasses of water every day our
urine should be relatively clear if it's
too dark yellow we're not doing a good
job of hydrating enough
how much of that is true
um is alkaline water worthwhile for
changing the alkalinity of my body I
learned when I was in college and
graduate school that the alkalinity of
the different tissues in your body is
very well controlled in order to keep
you alive and that you don't want it to
shift too much or you can enter pretty
horrible states of seizure vomiting and
even death so
tell me about hydration and woven into
that if you would
educate me on electrolytes and hydration
because I think most often when people
ingest electrolytes sure they could be
ingesting salt tablets
they're probably getting some
electrolytes by the way electrolyte
sodium magnesium potassium
through their food I think most people
think about drinking electrolytes so
water and electrolytes I think is a
vitally important topic to kick this off
with sure we can jump right into your
alkaline water while there's perhaps
much to say about this we can
maybe revisit this in another seven part
series all on its own uh I would just
say it this way
there's probably a few things you should
do before worrying about the alkalinity
of your water and I'll just leave it at
that
meaning the alkalinity of the water is
sort of irrelevant not that you won't go
that far is just it's probably remember
we started started off talking about 80
20. well this would be in my like 99 one
in terms of like if we're really at the
level of worrying about the pH of your
drinking fluid we have optimized so many
other things that then we can talk about
it but until we have nailed months and
years of work on other things this is
just not going to make much of an impact
great then perhaps you could tell us
about what volume of water we should be
drinking when we should be drinking that
water relative to training and just
generally and
um yeah and anything else relate to
water and electrolytes that can improve
mental Performance Physical performance
and offset any you know ill effects I
like the fact that you mentioned
physical and mental performance because
it's clear in both cases we hear that we
need to drink more water and I can give
you some numbers and I will in a second
what we also need to recognize is
there's this is hormesis we talked about
hormesis a few episodes ago and this is
the case right whether we talked about
food or hydration or I think I gave you
the example of cyanide
naturally occurring in your food hot
water is the same way so if you are
under hydrated or dehydrated then there
is a clear negative effect on your body
and as I increase the level or improve
the level of hydration things get better
whether this are physical performance or
whether this is mental performance in
fact we know that a body weight
reduction of as low as two percent via
dehydration so imagine you're doing a
bout of exercise and you're sweating and
you lose two percent of your body weight
that alone is enough to reduce accuracy
and performance so the classic study we
talk about here was in basketball
players so shooting accuracy so free
throw shooting I think is specifically
what they looked at
significant reduction in performance
with as little as two percent
dehydration that that level you also see
a significant increase in perception of
difficulty of exercise and so only right
at two percent
and again when I say two percent I mean
percent body weight lost right that's
what that means you start getting the
three four five percent dehydration you
start having a significant reduction in
blood volume and that's incredibly
important for endurance
um your blood becomes viscous it gets
hard to pump through
um and you're going to start having all
kinds of issues so being dehydrated is
again not only going to reduce
performance but because of the mental
aspect which we just walked through and
neuromuscular issue you're going to lose
accuracy you're going to lose total
endurance performance and you're going
to lose speed and power so we have the
Triad there no matter what you're
interested in it's going to be harmed by
being dehydrated that also is happening
then if you're starting your program
dehydrated so if you're already one
percent or so dehydrated maybe you're
like a little under hydrated and you
lose a little bit of sweat you've
already hit that two percent and so
we're starting to see reductions um in
performance there the same happens on
the other side of that hormetic curve so
if you are optimally hydrated in some
large window
but you start going past that we can
start running into equal problems
remember there's a there is a need for
an optimal concentration of sodium and
potassium and chloride between your cell
inside your cell and outside your cell
these are electrolytes this is what we
call osmolality and osmolarity is really
going to think of it like concentration
and osmosis if you remember those terms
so if we are trying to create a muscle
contraction that requires an electrical
gradient and so sodium and potassium
specifically in magnesium calcium are
positively charged and chloride is
negatively charged and we need to have a
certain amount inside the cell and
outside the cell so that the positives
and the negatives are balanced
appropriately so that when we move one
we change the voltage and we have in the
case of a muscle contraction
okay I just came through a whole lot of
physiology there to say if you then go
mess with fluid only and you say if I
were to give you a bolus of you know
three liters of pure water right now
you're going to dilute your blood and so
there's not going to be as many chemical
uh there won't be as many electrical
signals in there because you've taken
the same amount of sodium potassium Etc
and put it in a larger volume of pure
water so that gradient has now changed
that becomes a significant problem
for contraction I mean quite literally
it can kill you this is what we call
hyponatremia so notremia spelled n a
hypo being low
hyponatremia if you actually go to the
Periodic Chart n a is what we use for
sodium so hypernetes because the word is
natremia actually so that what that
literally means is low sodium and you
didn't get that from sweating out all
your sodium you actually get
hyponatremia from drinking in too much
water so it's not that the total amount
of sodium gets low it's the fact that
the concentration gets low from
excessive fluid intake so in the
Extremes in fact if you look at the
literature you'll see anywhere between
like two to fifteen percent of people
who finish endurance races are are into
hyponatremia now that varies wildly if
you're doing Iron Man and Kona versus
like you know the marathon in Denver in
in October right it's going to be
totally different depending on weather
conditions but these are all important
so while like death happens that is sort
of extreme if you back up just a little
bit you start seeing the same types of
performance sacraments in fact the
symptoms can be identical brain fog
confusion performance uh irritation a GI
distress and you think man these are
symptoms of dehydration so then you
drink more water and you're just
exacerbating the problem and I can
actually
um give you one little example of this
we had an executive actually female CEO
uh I'll say she's probably when I was in
her early 40s
and so she came to us and she thought
man for sure she has some sort of gut
problem going on because we hear a lot
about kind of like gut health and how it
affects everything and so she's just
like I have brain fog and I've done all
these things and I got blood work done
and everything's fine like nothing's
going on I think I must have some sort
of gut thinger going on or whatever and
it's okay and we just started going
through her stuff and uh she was I think
about 170 pounds plus or minus and she
was consuming like 250 to 60 ounces of
water a day
that's a ton of water and we were like
holy what are you doing this for
and she says like that's sort of like my
thing it was but she didn't realize it
was more of like a nervous tick than it
was anything else right she just like
sips of sip sip sip water I'm like man
how often do you go pee and she's like
yeah like every you know 30 minutes or
something I'm like fantastic sleep
problems focused and so she's smashing
caffeine she was at like eight cups of
coffee a day which is also going to add
to excretion of sodium
totally right
so it's like okay we don't really need
to come in and run a sleep study on you
we're just going to lower your water and
she was like what yeah we dropped her
down to like 180 so basically an ounce
per pound of body weight which is still
high because she did train 180 ounces
correct yeah she does work out so she
needed to replenish some stuff and we'll
cover these numbers in a second
instantaneously I mean like two days in
she's like oh my God I haven't slept six
to eight hours in years and then after
that it was like basically tears coming
back to us right my focus my brain fog
is gone because she's in a very high
pressure job
um it's like everything's coming back
like now she was down to three or so
cups off a day like the whole thing
digestion improved all of it she was
sick like to her only problem after all
the analyzes was she was just drinking
way way too much water and adding more
salt to her
would not have solved the problem
because she would have just had simply
way too much fluid in her system she was
having all kinds of ADH problems and
aldosterone like the whole thing and
then that that rolls into cortisol
the whole like system gets goes into
chaos so it is important that you pay
attention hydration even though as you
sort of mentioned people tend to just
kind of like roll their eyes around it
because if you're in the middle it's
fine but if you're anywhere past not
even the extreme extremes but just that
first standard deviation away you're
going to have problems and you might be
thinking adrenal fatigue you might be
thinking you're testing like you're
going to think all these things and you
simply just haven't actually dialed in
your hydration yeah uh I think people
sometimes roll their eyes at the
discussion of hydration because it just
doesn't sound very sexy it's not like
doesn't sound like a neurotransmitter or
a hormone it doesn't sound like
testosterone or estrogen or DHEA or
dopamine but it actually is all of those
things it sits at a level beneath all of
those but not beneath on a hierarchy
beneath in in terms of a foundation it's
actually the without
proper electrolyte balance and hydration
none of the cells of the body can
function and then I think people also
hear that oh you know we are 70 water
and somehow like it that statistic Alone
um or that fact alone doesn't seem to uh
stimulate any kind of action will take
away right it's like great you know uh
like gravity also you know keeps us you
know from jumping his eyes we like you
know what do I do and so I think
um it's it's important that people
understand that every cellular process
in the body critically relies on having
enough sodium magnesium potassium around
and the the way that it's concentrated
in fluid water is really the way that
you allow every cell in their body to
function as well as it possibly could
and respond to all the sorts of kind of
quote unquote High Performance Tools
that we're talking about the other thing
I've observed many times over is that if
people are ingesting too much water and
also drinking a lot of caffeine and
their electrolytes are low they get
shaky and they actually can have anxiety
like symptoms so when people come into
my lab to do studies on anxiety and fear
we ask a few questions and those
questions include how much water they've
had that day also a sort of bizarre fact
but one that I think is worth mentioning
is that when the bladder is full it
stimulates a sort of anxiety if you ever
had to urinate very badly and you're in
the car or you can't urinate and then
you get to the door like that's talk
about anxiety
um and that's because there's a direct
neural pathway from the bladder that
registers the mechanosensors how much
stretch there is on the bladder that
sends a signal to the brain stem
alertness
areas broadly speaking Locus ceruleus
and others that wake us up these are the
when we're awake it makes us more awake
and when we're asleep this is what wakes
us up to urinate in the middle of the
night yeah that's actually why you can
use uh night urination as a pretty good
diagnostic of sleep disorders
so if because of vasopressin right
almost exactly what you're talking about
if you're having sleep disorder issues
and you're staying awake and a
vasopressin gets taken off right an APN
goes straight to the kidneys your
kidneys are supposed to be dormant
basically at night you're not supposed
to be filtering a lot and producing a
lot of urine at night if that's
happening and say you you have any
number of apneas kicking on or anything
going on vasopressin keeps going keep
sending signal kidneys start filtering
so if you're waking up and peeing
multiple times a night that's called
nocturia that is a very very good sign
that either one of two things happen you
one you have some sort of sleep disorder
or two you're drinking outrageous
amounts of water and so that's actually
a bit of a backward cycle now right
because you're drinking way too much
water you're waking up and peeing all
night that's actually ruining your sleep
and so we have seen this a number of
times with our sleep company as we go in
and it's just like you don't need any of
this crap you just need to be properly
hydrated alternatively if your hydration
is sound and you're still waking up more
than one time a night to pee on average
then you almost well I shouldn't say
like that but there's a potential that
you actually have some sort of sleep
system or sleep condition going in so
the rule of thumb on that is so we're
here once or night once a night or so of
urination is fine if it is routinely or
consistently more than two you need to
make some adjustments start with
hydration it's the simplest way right
getting a full sleep study done just
figure out hydration we've had this
happen
a number of times where people want to
get more health conscious and they just
get they hear things like this and
they're like I gotta get on my water and
then they just start train wrecking
their sleep and then waking it up so if
you're waking up multiple times and
you're urinating and it is a large
amount of urine for you and it is clear
that's probably not sleep apne induced
noctria that's probably excessive
hydration if you're waking up a bunch of
times and it's fairly small amounts of
urine then it's probably not the fluid
issue it's probably the fact that the
vasopressin is kicking your kidneys into
gear so that's not a perfect criteria
but it's just like a quick little tool
you can sort of use that's actually one
of the reasons why we measure almost
always your body weight at night
as well as in the morning so that that's
like the combat sport in the UFC
fighters boxers we call that your float
so how much you floated overnight I like
to know that number because I want to
know as well your first morning void so
when you wake up then you went to bed at
200 pounds you woke up the next morning
at 195. it's like oh you floated five
pounds
did you pee last night yeah yeah three
times
interesting another case you woke up you
went to bed at 200 pounds you wake up at
199.5
okay you're dehydrated because you
should have a a certain amount of fluid
that you're just Whispering out as
you're breathing throughout your nose
throughout night ideally uh guaranteed
you're gonna wake up what was your urine
like oh yeah a little bit pretty dark
like shocker you're dehydrated so you
can kind of look at numbers like that a
general float is something like a pound
to two pounds for the 170 plus pound
person as you scale up that number then
go up a little bit but you can kind of
use these to triage a little bit about
what's going on
um with this kind of combination
everything is everything right so it's
like it's not just about one system so
you're gonna pay attention you can also
look uh well I don't if you don't jump
into it we can but there's a whole bunch
of ways I can teach you to diagnose
hydration and maybe we can start there
and then we can talk about hydration
numbers yes I'd love to talk about
diagnostics for hydration over hydration
dehydration
to start off would you be willing to
give us some numbers how much water
should we be drinking the classic rule
here and you're making me do what I hate
right I want to give all the caveats
first but I'll go straight to your
number half an ounce per pound of body
weight is a rough rule so if you weigh
again 200 pounds that would mean you
drink 100 ounces of water a day most
water bottles are like 12 to 20 ounces
something like that so you know you end
up drinking six of those or so a day
kind of like plus or minus which is not
that unreasonable
this does depend on a number of factors
which I could go over but that is a
rough starting place the only other
thing to add to that is that does not
account for exercise induced water loss
or sauna or anything like that so that's
assuming just like basal daily needs if
you are exercising or sweating at all
for any reasons or work related so folks
that work outside are in the Heat or
a human environment these numbers all
change and you can slide this scale up
but you generally want to drink about
125 percent
of the fluids you've lost during that
physical activity back and how much do
you lose per hour of exercise that
number ranges between one to five pounds
depending on the person it can even be
higher with some of our athletes like I
can think of a number of NFL players
right now it's not uncommon for those
guys to do eight or nine pounds even not
even like crazy circumstances if it's
August and we're in Jacksonville
it's not wild for us those guys go nine
ten pounds but what about the typical
person who goes to a air-conditioned gym
or goes out for a run on a day that is
somewhere between let's say 55 degrees
Fahrenheit and 85 degrees Fahrenheit
you're probably looking at like a pound
it's not extremely high if you are
totally soaked
might be like a pound and a half to two
pounds if you're like come back and like
your pits are a little sweaty and
there's a little bit of water kind of on
your neckline it's probably like a more
like a pound or so so in that case you
might drink back a pound and a half of
water okay so just to review these
numbers to make sure that I'm
on the correct page here
a half an ounce of fluid per pound of
body weight is a sort of a foundation
for hydration
and then
you want to replace a hundred and twenty
five percent of the fluid lost during
exercise and exercise
varies where exercise is done varies
whether or not people are wearing
uniforms or helmets is going to impact
how much fluid they lose Etc
in a very hot environment that the
amount of fluid lost can be anywhere
from you know one to five maybe even ten
pounds easy per hour of hard hard
exertion for most exercise done in
conditions of 55 degrees Fahrenheit to
72 excuse me 85 degrees Fahrenheit done
with some degree of effort one might
lose a pound or or two pounds of water
super easy way to find out all you have
to do is weigh yourself naked
go do your workout come back in dry off
weigh yourself naked that'll tell you
exactly what you lost so if you went in
you were 160 pounds you come back out
you wait you're 158 you lost two pounds
drink back two and a half pounds of
water you're good so that is uh is that
honestly it's like fairly gold standard
for identifying you can actually buy a
whole bunch of technology for this and
they are using the exact same equation
which is your body weight
when you were there now if you do that
though you do need to account for any
fluid you drink during the workout sure
because that then offsets it
simple but I think important question
we're talking about a half an ounce of
fluid per pound of body weight does that
include things like coffee tea soda
pre-workout drinks mid-workout drinks uh
mate matcha whatever the you know
there's a yerba mate there's a there are
a million things out there
um or just
water any fluid for the most part is
going to count
and is it true that fluids that contain
caffeine
generally cause us to secrete sodium
yeah
okay so do you recommend including
electrolyte powder or a small pinch of
sodium or any number of other supplement
type electrolytes that can replace that
sodium magnesium and potassium a couple
of things we have to pay attention to
accurately answer that question
well you also sort of asked about you
may have not even realize is does
caffeine actually enhance dehydration
which is not really what you asked but
it's probably a lot of people thought
that as well so caffeine can
but coffee doesn't necessarily do that
because remember you're co-ingesting
that with fluid and so uh we used to say
that all the time how coffee dehydrates
you it doesn't it might make your urine
yellow that certainly gives off a odor
in your urine but in general coffee will
not do that because you're just if you
were to now be taking caffeine pills
alone now there is a bit of a diuretic
effect there and so you're going to year
and how much
maybe not enough for you to be really
concerned with especially when you
balance that against the ergogenic
effects and benefits of caffeine it's
not something we are concerned about
second part of your question do you need
to then offset the loss
of sodium I'm not super concerned about
the amount of sodium lost to caffeine I
am more concerned about simply the
amount of sodium being correct
because of the bigger circumstances like
how much is actually in your system and
how much you lost
in the training session so it's not the
caffeine that I care about that much
relative to you know if you lost three
grams of sodium because of the training
and you added another few milligrams
because the caffeine I don't really care
or didn't I'm glad you brought up the
difference between a substance like
caffeine and the vehicle It's contained
in like coffee this is all really
important and it also raises a question
about individual differences in sweating
ability and I call it sweating ability
because I have a good friend I've known
for ages really
um actually work with him in my
laboratory as well and he's one of these
people that the moment he starts any
physical activity it's like a flood
warning right he just soaks through
clothing it's just the sweating
adaptation is is exceedingly robust in
him other people less so so is it true
that sweating in our ability to dump
heat through it by loss of water is
something that um we tend to vary on and
that also that we can build up that
capacity I know a number of people are
probably thinking ew gross why would I
want to sweat more but there's actually
a huge advantage to be able to dump body
heat during exertion because body heat
in some ways sets the cap for
performance a lot many many ways
including mental performance
is stay alert often is enhanced by being
cold and of course we all want to warm
up properly but
um in terms of loss of fluid through
sweating is there a way to easily bin
ourselves into kind of a low sweater
medium sweater heavy sweater that sounds
like an article of clothing but in any
case you know what I'm you know man
another a lot to say here we should wish
we had a whole series on this listen if
we have to go 17 hours we can do it just
everybody hydrate well I think we've
shown the listeners uh that is a real
threat
that's a very real threat podcasting to
failure you don't have to do every set
in the gym to failure but here we are
attempting a podcast failure in it in
all seriousness
um what what is the role of
sweating ability and is this something
that any of us should care about or
train for or pay attention to or is this
just kind of getting into the Arcane
number one you can train your ability to
sweat this is important for heat
acclimation and why that matters when
you sweat that actually is not what
regulates your temperature uh you what
you want to have happen is the fluid to
hit your skin and that to be evaporated
that's the actual mechanism so in fact
if you stop sweating and like you can
guarantee within a short amount of time
you're going to be done moving oh very
interesting I hope people heard that and
really are are highlighting that in
their mind that sweating is a process of
bringing fluid from your body onto the
surface of your skin and then the heat
dumping aspect of sweating is the
evaporation of that off off your body
which brings to mind all sorts of ideas
about how to dress during exercise Etc
but what you said is that if you are not
sweating enough you are limiting your
output capacity so it's not just about
having enough fluid to switch wet yeah
it's also about being able to sweat and
being uh
dressed appropriately to allow that
sweat to move to evaporate off your body
yep and heat acclimation training is as
simple as it sounds so just practice it
more so if you're going into a process
where you either need to be in a hot
environment or you need to improve your
sweat rate you just need to practice
sweating and your body will get compared
to that I practice the sauna practice a
Jacuzzi just get in those things and you
will improve your ability to do that now
there is a huge genetic component I have
one individual actually a UFC fighter
I've been working with and I don't mind
mentioning his name he'll give me full
permission Scott Holtzman many many
years
um
he's actually fighting right now
actually today he'll be going he is like
he he is like you described like buckets
and buckets and buckets of fluids come
off this guy when he's tying his shoes
like he just goes right like and we've
we've improved that I actually sweat too
much we worked on that a lot early in
his career and we got some improvements
down to get him to hold on to the fluids
better that being said I've worked at
the other individuals in his weight
category and it's the opposite right so
we can have them literally do the exact
same training session together and Scott
will dump six pounds and other folks at
his size will dump two two and a half so
there's a genetic component that is just
there and you don't need to worry about
it there
um so can you identify if you are
a heavy salt sweater or not well you
have a whole bunch of routes for this
number one is you can use the old free
cost free test of just looking at your
clothing and if you're seeing that white
residue all over it so you've you've all
have the friend who probably wears that
same baseball hat that they've had for
eight years if it is covered in the
white junk all over the place that's a
sign of a higher salt sweater if the
opposite happens and it's like you can
pull their clothing back and there's
just nothing there they are maybe a
little bit of a lower salt sweater you
can also
use any number of hydration tests I know
that there is some coming out in the
market very very soon that can give you
theoretically real time
measurements it's like a CGM would be
although I haven't seen any data on if
those are accurate or not I haven't used
one yet but there are a number that are
out super cheap you know 10 15 20 bucks
all the way up to a couple hundred
dollars you can buy these patches put
them on you and get a reasonably close
estimate and again if those things are 5
or 10 or 20 off I don't know I have to
see independent data come out first but
even if they are you're not worried
about the specific milligrams right
whether you sweat out you know 1250
milligrams in a workout or if it's 1340
it doesn't really matter you're trying
to look for big big numbers right are
you losing 500 milligrams using three
and a half grams while you're at so
those things will get you in a ballpark
to do exactly what you decide am I high
medium or low and there's a lot of them
that I've used in the past so
that that's another way to go about it
then what you want to do is probably
match your electrolyte intake to
something close to what you sweat that's
the ideal scenario you can get a lot of
information about hydration from blood
you can look at like acute markers of
dehydration like hemoglobin hematocrit
if you're like if your hemoglobin is
like 15 plus
it's funny we've talked about this in a
few episodes before but I see that and
I'm like man that dude's super fit
that's like a 15 uh for him would be
pretty high 14 or so would be pretty
good for a female that's also the exact
same thing as a sign of acute
dehydration
um so hematocrite same thing if you're
north of 50 you're probably dehydrated
so you can get a lot there are also
though a lot of biomarkers that can tell
you more about chronic dehydration so
you can run through those things as well
so good blood chemistry test can tell
you a lot and you can actually get some
insights in your sodium and potassium
albumin is another fantastic way to
measure longer term uh hydration status
now one of these amazing globulins that
we've sort of talked a lot about
so you can do all those things you can
also simply measure the body weight pre
and post and use a sweat patch or not
and use the the Freer version of your
clothing test and get a rough idea of
where you're getting it from so
those are good places to start
I want to go back though and make sure I
wasn't over terrifying the audience too
much on a server piece if you're
performing a type of training or
exercise or sport in which you're not
losing more than two percent of your
body weight you don't need to be overly
concerned about hydrating in the sport
and so we can actually get into
some equations for how much water to
drink during training right now but if
you if you're again losing less than
that it's not critical you can have some
fluids it like makes you feel better but
you're not going to be experiencing
tremendous amounts of performance
sacraments if you're you know again out
playing a baseball game and is 50
degrees out you're fine um you can drink
some water but that's not going to be
compromising performance or recovery so
we can actually then if you'd like I can
go through the three-step system for
optimizing hydration but those are I
want to make sure I planted that flag so
people aren't just terrified that they
got to be guzzling down water if they're
you know going to their physical
therapist for some stretching that's
probably not super important I'd like to
take a brief break and acknowledge our
sponsor at athletic greens athletic
greens is a vitamin mineral probiotic
and adaptogen drink designed to help you
meet all of your foundational
nutritional needs I've been taking
athletic greens daily since 2012. so I'm
delighted that they're a sponsor of this
podcast the reason I started taking
athletic greens and the reason I still
take athletic greens once or twice a day
is that it helps me meet all of my
foundational nutritional needs that is
it covers my vitamins my minerals and
the probiotics are especially important
to me athletic greens also contains
adaptogens which are critical for
recovering from stress from exercise
from work or just general life if you'd
like to try athletic greens you can go
to athleticgreens.com huberman to claim
a special offer they'll give you five
free travel packs and they'll give you a
year's supply of vitamin d3k2 again if
you'd like to try athletic greens go to
athleticgreens.com huberman to claim the
special offer I would love for you to
tell us what I refer to as the Galpin
equation understanding of course that
you did not name it the Galpin equation
listen folks scientists can have things
named after them but in general it's not
reflective of healthy psychology if they
name things after themselves correct
sometimes yes neuroanatomists used to do
that but in any case Dr Andy Galpin did
not name the Galpin equation after
himself I named it after him and the
Galpin equation for how much fluid to
ingest during exercise is
you want to take your body weight in
pounds and divide that by 30 and you
want to consume that number which would
be in ounces about every 15 to 20
minutes so in the example of you being
200 pounds you would take 200 divided by
30 which is let's just call that number
seven to be close which means you would
consume about seven ounces of water
every 15 or 20 minutes or so okay now as
a little bit of a point while I also did
not name it I also didn't do the
research it's important to point out
that other scientists figured these
things out I just read their papers and
made that derivation of their equation
to make it a little bit easier for us
folks who do not work on the metric
system okay a couple of things first of
all I'm not 200 pounds but it doesn't
matter how much I weigh because the
point is that the listener
correct should take their body weight in
pounds divided by 30 in just that number
of ounces in fluid every 15 minutes and
then for those out there outside the US
that are accustomed to thinking in
milliliters and liters not ounces and
kilograms not pounds
what is the Galpin equation in the
metric system this would be two
milliliters per kilogram
which again if you were let's say 200
pounds that's going to be something
roughly like we'll call it 90 kilos
and so if you did two milliliters per
kilo you'd be something like 180
milliliters of fluid again every 15 or
20 minutes
great and how should people ingest that
fluid and of course I would imagine it's
through their mouth um I would hope I
hope there are other orifices that it
might suffice but let's not go there
they're drinking that water consistently
or is it every 15 minutes they Slug it
back does it matter okay yeah that's
very good a handful of things
in general when you talk hydration the
slower and steady you can go the better
in fact the reason these this two
milliliters per kilogram number came out
is because a number of Trials were run
when they looked at that every 15
minutes just one bolus of it you know
um in different derivations and it's
pretty clear that the slower Pace one
could do it the better so whether you're
doing it every 10 minutes or 15 or 20
minutes the reason we actually give that
Gap is because you have to be also
offset a little bit of GI distress in
fact like kind of the the four golden
rules of recovery if you will
um we use sort of three R's you need to
rebuild rehydrate and replenish what
that really means is you need to have a
continuous glucose stream
you need to have a continuous amino acid
stream you need to hydrate and you need
to do all one two and three without
disturbing your gut too much
and so in this particular case
it was sort of found that we can hit
that level in general
and be just fine for most people so I
mean a little bit of context the example
we gave there in both cases it's
something like six to seven ounces for
15 or 20 minutes if you think about that
there's 16 ounces in a pound
and most water bottles like if you go
buy a water bottle in a store here it's
they generally come in like 16 ounce
bottles ish so six or seven ounces is
really like a third
of a water bottle Maybe
every 15 or 20 or so minutes so it's not
some egregious amount of water that you
have to slam down now that is influenced
heavily by how hydrated you started the
session with so how high are you came in
external factors like heat humidity
temperature things like that but that
gives you a rough idea that again and
these are numbers that you would need to
consume to optimize performance
at the end of that then is when you
would look to see how much I lost like
we talked about earlier
and then add back that 125 percent
taking into account how much fluid you
ingested so if you're 200 pounds and you
drink a total of say a pound of water
during the training and you started off
at 200 and you finished at 198.
you actually lost three pounds
not two pounds because you lost three
you drank one during it so your final
net number is two so now you don't you
really need to drink back 125 of that
remaining two pounds
two and a half pounds something like
that these numbers especially that 125
are they're just rough guidelines some
actually papers suggest it's all the way
up to 150 percent
so it's just like an idea don't measure
out whether you need 5.5 ounces or 6.2
ounces like it just sort of gives you an
idea of where to start all right a few
sips every 15 or 20 minutes is close
enough
I've actually started using uh the
Galpin equation to determine how much
fluid I need for mental work given the
now robust data that are out there on
the relationship between hydration and
mental work it's
um been very effective for me and again
there are peer-reviewed studies that
that support the idea that hydration is
important for proper mental Clarity and
energy and focus and that even being
slightly dehydrated can disrupt that but
if one is drinking so much water that
they're frequently going to the restroom
and can't comfortably uh focus on the
work they're doing that's also an issue
so
um that's very helpful what are the
three most critical features of
hydration and then I'd like to move on
to
um some of the more particulars about
supplementation and nutrition three
parts start hydrated
maintain hydration throughout
part three is hydrate post to fix it
okay we gave you the half ounce per
pound of body weight equation so you
start the training hydrated we gave you
the
you know two milliliters per kilogram
slash body weight divided by 30.
to stay hydrated let me give you the 125
but I can actually just give you sort of
I'm giving you another list here I'm
sorry but it is my five-step cheater
guide
for optimizing hydration for performance
all right step number one drink a lot of
water first thing in the morning this
gets everything kickstarted get you
going it also saves you from having to
drink a bunch of water at night which is
then going to compromise your sleep
what's a lot depending on how big you
are the general thing I'll tell people
is like one of the very first things you
should do throughout your day you wake
up
go to the bathroom as you're consuming
your sunlight consume water this is
maybe chugging a full glass that's
honestly what I do it's not the best
route but I'll just get 16 ounces 16
ounces or so is great it's fine if
you're larger
um you know I'm 165 to 70 pounds
depending on what's going on maybe a
little higher sometimes if you're 225
pounds maybe that number is 30 ounces
okay so you just sort of scale up and
down and the only reason I say a lot is
it just depends on what you're doing and
I also should clarify I don't really
literally mean chug just like sips
because the faster you drink water the
faster it's going to expand blood volume
the faster it stands blood volume the
faster you get rid of it
um I don't think a lot of people will
know that yeah this is maybe this is
clarifying this is also we sort of
talked about earlier if you drink too
much water you'll dilute the system well
if you have a diluted system your body's
first reaction is to rid of water to
bring total blood volume down right
remember if you were to go to a doctor
and they look at your total blood volume
they're like man you're five and a half
liters you're gonna be like holy crap
you're going to be put on a diuretic
because you don't want to have a heart
attack blood pressure I wonder if people
are drinking a 16 ounce glass of water
or other fluid all at once before going
to sleep and that's why they're waking
up in the middle of the night totally
given what you just said probably a
better
um protocol would be to sip on a glass
of water in the final hour two hours
before sleep generally the number we say
is three hours in the three hours
proceeding sleep you want to basically
limit fluid intake to sipping as needed
I think that's I'm going to start that
tonight because I wake up generally once
per night to use the bathroom and I do
drink some fluids before I go to sleep
mostly because I'm pretty thirsty at
that time yeah
um but I'm gonna start sipping that
water in the uh three hours heading into
sleep yeah so you can actually pay
attention to his um
to go back this is actually I love doing
this stuff but if you're waking up at
night and you have a very dry mouth
not for me all right because it can be
one of two things you might actually be
dehydrated and so then what the mistake
people make is like man my mouth is so
dry I keep getting up to drink water at
night that makes you then pee too much
what that also indicates is probably
your mouth breathing so a lot of ways to
fix people waking up and urinating too
much at night is to tape your mouth and
or use a dilator over your nose and then
what happens is you don't feel like you
have a dry mouth so you don't get up to
consume any extra water throughout the
night so that actually reduces your your
fluid intake so you don't have the
problem of actually now having too much
fluid to do it and so it's another
reasons why mouth taping can really
really help and
if you are having those issues and or
snoring those are not benign that's a
really like you really should get some
work on those um something you're not
sleeping very well is the way I'll say
it it doesn't doesn't necessarily mean
something life-threatening but it's not
a good thing so you're going to run kind
of your triaging things back and forth
so if you're like I'm waking up to pee a
lot but my mouth isn't thirsty okay
great then you may actually have just a
water consumption issue if it is my
mouth is dry but I'm actually waking up
and I'm having these large urinations
then you're not actually dehydrated
you're just breathing through your mouth
if you're waking up and your mouth is
dry
and there's not a lot of pee there then
you actually might actually legitimately
be under hydrated so a little bit of a
game you can play there well that's
super informative I think that
um the point alone that
gulping a bunch of water all at once is
going to cause you to need to excrete
that water
soon after
um is a really important point also for
people that are going to I don't know
give a talk or um you don't want to have
to get up to use the restroom you have
to sit through a long meeting yeah um
clearly I'm violating all these rules up
until right now I've been you know not I
sort of followed the seagull approach to
uh to consuming fluids just in
um enormous volumes I'm going to start
sipping um fluids instead
um what are some of the other rules of
hydration so you're going to wake up
you're going to start your day and start
hydrated so you know you're consuming a
larger percentage of your water earlier
in the day then you get all the
performance enhancing effects of water
and you don't have to worry about it
compromising your sleep so that's step
number one also now you're gonna start
your session closer to hydration all
right great number two eat mostly real
Whole Foods
why
interesting what you may or not have
thought about is a huge determinant of
your hydration status is your food
choices if you look at different foods
for example most fruit watermelon
watermelon is like 95 plus percent water
fantastic Source also by the way since
we're here it is not extremely high in
carbohydrate it's not extremely high in
sugar it is by percentage but since it
is almost exclusively water you're
eating it is not something that is
extremely dangerous in terms of sugar I
there alone probably all the things
we've talked about in the six six
episodes uh that comment right there
will probably blow the internet to
pieces and I'll probably get hate mail
for life for it but from people
water throwing watermelons yeah yeah oh
my gosh well I don't think the point is
that sugar is necessarily bad I think
the point is that for most people
they're ingesting too much sugar most
people yeah um and it's interesting
oftentimes the people who are justifying
the ingestion of sugar are exactly the
kind of people that should not ingest so
much sugar so there's a little bit of a
well a user bias the point here is if
you're eating whole real food this is
like now we're kind of splitting hairs
about those things so
so morning hydration
yeah now important Point here
if you compare it to other Foods
um like actually meat is is a very high
percentage of fluid depending on how
well or long you've cooked it you just
remember you said earlier over 70 water
right so if you're eating meat you're
getting actually a big chunk of water as
you cook it of course you lose some of
that but meat can be like I wouldn't
call it a hydrating food item but it is
not as low as something like a biscuit
which can be actually like 10 water
that's why it's like dry and dense which
doesn't mean it's bad for you but there
if you're eating highly processed foods
almost by association that means they've
been dehydrated
or portionably right so you're just
getting less total fluid intake in
addition they have also been highly
salted
in general right so now we're in this
position where we're under hydrated and
highly salted bad spot if you now switch
over to mostly again just mostly whole
real food-ish whatever that means to you
then your hydration is going to
Skyrocket you're going to have a lot so
you're eating a ton of food in fact it
should be a large percentage of the
fluid intake you have actually should be
coming from your food you shouldn't have
to be smashing water bottles after a
water bottle all day in that case though
you do need to add salt back so we do
see this a lot with people who try to
make a transition from maybe a
sub-optimal Nutritional Lifestyle and
they give up a little bit of other
processed food and they come over and
they start having problems because
they're not actually consuming enough
salt
so add that back easy way to do that you
can use electrolytes and we could talk
about those numbers if you want if you
just salt your food that you're making
you know to taste that's going to get
most people in a pretty good spot so
start hydrated
consume hydrating Foods
step number two step number three
you want to pre-hydrate if you know
you're going to do a workout session
and it's going to be hot and long or one
of those things you want to look for
that half a pound a per body weight of
ounces so that's the number we're
looking for to start our hydration
session we do that we're pretty much
taken care of and then like I said
adjust depending on lifestyle humidity
and other factors like that you can use
what is called the what
system w-u-t I think Bob kennethick has
done a ton of research in this area if
you want to read more look up his
research it is simply weight
urine and thirst so in other words check
your body weight
look at your urine color and engage your
thirst and actually you can use through
those three things and those can
significantly predict actual hydration
status independent of actually measuring
osmolality or anything like that so
those three metrics alone are pretty
good indicator
of where you're at so you're going to
have that normal amount of water plus or
minus
if you miss that number for whatever
reason you get distracted the number we
typically tell people is like something
like 400 to 500 milliliters of water in
the hour proceeding the training all
right so that's like 13 to 20 ounces
so like you know you're gonna go work
out at three o'clock it's two o'clock
and you realize oh man I have not
drinking much water today
you don't need to go smash tons and tons
and tons just look for something like
that you know call it a bottle of water
if you will if that's not enough if
you're in a really tough spot you can do
more like uh five to eight ounces
15 or 20 minutes before exercise
you want to be really careful about
drinking a bunch of water like in the
seconds before exercise
because you're just going to feel a
whole bunch of water bouncing up and
down in your stomach and nobody likes
that so one to three hundred milliliters
15 or so 20 minutes before that assumes
you're in this like
185 pound range ish again if you're
talking people of much larger size you
may need to increase those values
accordingly if you do all that
then you use the Galpin equation for
your intra workout hydration and you're
in a pretty good spot
what you want to consume in that is what
I call Sweat
what I mean by that is you don't
actually want to necessarily consume
water only during a workout you want to
consume something that is ISO osmotic to
your blood
so something that is the same
concentration
that you lost in your sweat so if you've
done a sweat test you would then drink a
fluid that is of the same osmolality the
short version of that
something in the neighborhood of 200 to
400 milligrams of sodium most
electrolytes products are going to be
something like that now I know element
is is a thousand milligrams and it's a
lot higher but most products now that
you're going to find are 250 to 400
milligrams and they're typically in the
like two
to maybe up to three to one sodium to
potassium range right coconut water is
actually cool it's like basically the
opposite like a cup of coconut water I
think has something like 200 milligrams
of sodium but like 600 milligrams of
potassium so um like total spoiler alert
but will we use coconut water a lot of
hydration just add a little pinch of
salt because that'll bring the sodium
way back up yeah one note about sodium
um obviously people who have
pre-hypertension or hypertension want to
be careful with their sodium intake
um anytime I've suggested that people
might consider ingesting more sodium you
know it's sort of uh it's like it's like
putting a Target on your on your back
and yet the data are pretty good showing
that if people are not getting enough
sodium
their mental Clarity their focus their
mental stamina their physical stamina
really suffers
and then people argue well most of us
are getting too much salt that often is
true for people that are eating a lot of
processed foods and not training and not
training but for many uh people who are
already sort of health conscious who are
training they're largely consuming
or I should say they're consuming
largely non-processed or minimally
processed foods and especially for folks
who are not ingesting many carbohydrates
and are consuming caffeine totally you
know a lot of people don't know that
carbohydrates hold water and that makes
it sound bad it's not necessarily that
you know you're going to get
subcutaneous swelling of your body now
it's recovery it's it's bringing water
into your system and it holds water so
when you drop carbohydrate starches in
particular you urinate a lot more and
when you drink caffeine you also urinate
a lot more as as you pointed out earlier
so you start combining a few things like
slightly lower carbohydrate or low
carbohydrate eating really quote unquote
clean you're not getting a lot of salt
in your food and drinking caffeine and
then exercising and then pretty soon
those numbers that come along with um
you know a gram of sodium in your
electrolyte drink are not all that
outrageous and what you find is people
feel much much better when they're
getting enough sodium and of course I
should um say that there's no reason why
someone has to ingest a supplement like
element or something there are plenty of
other ways to bring sodium into your
system you use a pinch of pink salt or
Himalayan salt or sea salt or even just
table salt in water or just making sure
that you're salting your food enough and
I think that there too salt appetite and
salt taste is a pretty good guide if you
taste something and it tastes really
salty to you that's an indication that
either it's really salty or your salt
stores are kind of tapped off you're
okay whereas if you're craving salt and
you and you're thinking gosh I really
want to put salt on this already salty
thing
not necessarily but oftentimes that
means that you are salt efficient so
salt appetite is a pretty hardwired set
of neural circuits and hormones and I
think we would all be wise to learn to
tap into the our kind of intuition about
salt intake but of course also to
measure your blood pressure Etc yeah of
course if you think you have some sort
of contraindication there that work with
the medical specialist without without
question
um those situations you laid out though
are very real a lot of people are living
like that and so it's important for
those folks to understand if you are
going through symptoms fatigue
lack of focus cognitive function
performance isn't there then hey like
you may be under salted and again
actually a good amount of blood
chemistry work can unravel that a lot
and it can sort of tell you if you're
going out of whack there are a number of
folks who are
extremely sensitive to sodium in terms
of health risk and that that is a real
thing again work with your
um individual folks on that I don't work
with anyone for disease treatment or
management at all I've said that
probably four times I'll say it six more
times
um I only take people who are healthy
and try to make them perform at their
best possible level so it's actually
funny you mentioned that because I was
going to give people my recommendation
for sodium intake in general throughout
the day and then I decided I'm not going
to say that because all it's going to do
is make all the rest of the people who
aren't coming to come after me for the
watermelon comment come after me for
that so by the end of today's episode
the goal is that there everyone's coming
after you but also everyone has learned
something of value you've already given
us a tremendous insights and actionable
information on Creatine and hydration
and
along those lines I'd love for you to
tell us about some of the things that we
can do with supplementation in order to
enhance training by taking certain
things before we train and I also have
the question of how
long before training should we start
thinking about supplying nutrients and
supplements for the training session I'm
not sure I've actually finished my fiber
maybe I wasn't clear enough about the
last one so I just want to tie that that
bow and then we'll go to the next one
yeah no it was probably my fault so
that uh in addition to the
Galloping equation in terms of amount uh
I'm recording I recommended at you know
roughly three to one sodium to potassium
recommendation and I gave you some rough
numbers for things like that I actually
in all honesty use probably six to ten
different electrolyte companies
depending on the situation some of them
are really good in the case again like
element that's nice about that is
there's no carbohydrate however the
downside is there's no carbohydrate so
sometimes I want carbohydrates in the
training because as you mentioned
there's significant evidence going back
actually several decades on the benefit
of carbohydrate during exercise so if
you're in a situation uh where you're
trying to again maximize actual exercise
performance you especially if it is
either long duration so more than two
hours
or extremely high intensity and this has
to be well north of 100 of your VO2 max
in that situation as we talked about in
the endurance episode you can actually
start having a decrement performance
because of a drop of muscle glycogen uh
Global glycogen can start coming down if
that's the case augmenting with
carbohydrates during the training that
is going to enhance performance it's
going to do what we call spare the liver
and it's going to keep my second rule of
my four which is maintain a glucose
ingestion it's going to keep that going
in general what you're going to find is
the number is like a five to nine
percent glucose concentration in your
fluid which turns out to be like exactly
the number that most sports drinks have
as well as I think that's pretty much
exactly what a coconut water is the
downside of sports drinks since we're
here is they actually tend to be
undersalted and so that they don't
provide enough of them if you look at
the numbers they're going to say
something like 60 to 100 grams of
carbohydrate per hour
is the Target and now if you're using
the sort of Galloping equation and
you're splitting that up into 15
minute intervals it's something again
like 20 or so grams of carbs per 15 to
20 minutes
if you're doing again an hour long plus
training though so admittedly 100 grams
uh is a bit much for some folks
depending on your size so I would
recommend starting in that uh 60 gram or
so range again per hour total is what
you want to get to and only in the
situation in which muscle glycogen
depletion is becoming a limiting factor
to Performance so the other benefit of
that is as you mentioned that actually
drives water into the cell and so you're
going to be in that nice sweet spot of
you're actually keeping glucose going
which is going to enhance performance
and you're helping hydration at the same
time so the other little part that's
important to pay attention to here is
the type of carbohydrate matters so you
can use actually a whole combination of
things called resistant starches which I
will use for a long bouts of exercise
but in the middle of the workout you're
going to want to focus on glucose and
fructose mostly glucose typically at
least a two or three to one ratio of
glucose to fructose and the reason is
those actually get into tissue through
separate Transporters and so what
happens is once the glucose Transporters
get full you can't bring anything else
in however since fructose comes in a
separate route you can maximize total
carbohydrate intake by using two
different unique forms there's a lot of
ways you can do this but this is where
the momentous fuel product is is that
specifically has that exactly in it so
it's fantastic you can use food no
problem you can use the combination of
things like honey and different easily
absorbable and usable and things that
you can actually like maybe put in a
drink to get away with so there's lots
of routes for it but you want to look in
that that sort of combination of five to
nine percent roughly glucose for there
so you do need to train your gut so do
not do anything and there's a generally
A good rule do not do anything in your
competition
that you've never done in practice so
try these food items try these amounts
the carbohydrate numbers try the sodium
numbers try the total amount of water
start low
you can always increase what you don't
want to do is have to run out during the
middle of your spin class and Sprint to
the bathroom and hope nobody's in your
way which in the lab we've seen
we'll just say accidents like that occur
more than once so just be careful of
your stomach I'd like to take a brief
break to acknowledge our sponsor inside
tracker inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
reach your health goals I've long been a
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that many of
the factors that impact your immediate
and long-term health and well-being can
only be analyzed from a quality blood
test one issue with a lot of blood tests
and DNA tests out there however is that
you get information back about various
levels of lipids and hormones and
metabolic factors Etc but you don't know
what to do with that information inside
tracker makes knowing what to do with
all that information exceedingly easy
they have a personalized platform that
lets you see what your specific numbers
are of course but then also what sorts
of Behavioral do's and don'ts what sorts
of nutritional changes what sorts of
supplementation would allow you to bring
those levels into the ranges that are
optimal for you if you'd like to try
inside tracker you can visit
insidetracker.com
and to get 20 off any of inside
tracker's plans again that's inside
tracker.com huberman to get 20 off I
realize I jumped the gun a little bit
asking about supplementation for before
during and after a workout
um because what I neglected to ask about
was training in the fasted State this is
something that we talked about in an
earlier episode but I think it's worth
highlighting now
um Sometimes the best way to supplement
if you will a workout or pre-workout is
ingesting nothing I'm one of these
people I actually prefer to do my weight
training somewhere between seven and
eight a.m each morning sometimes a
little earlier sometimes a little bit
later
I drink
fluid water and I do ingest caffeine
prior to those training days on days
when I don't train I do as I often
recommend uh people do delay my caffeine
intake 90 to 120 minutes after waking
but in any event
it's water and caffeine yerba mate or
coffee or some sort of stimulant for
weight training workouts
and generally not for cardiovascular
training workouts although sometimes yes
so I'm training fasted that said I'm
ingesting carbohydrate the night before
to make sure that my I have glycogen
stores that are topped off and uh so
it's fasted but with that caveat what
are your thoughts on training fasted and
what I just described is fasted
overnight but some people are training
in the afternoon and they may opt to not
eat anything in the you know two to four
hours prior to training or maybe even
longer I personally find that caffeine
hits my system a lot better when I'm
fasted better meaning it just seems to
have more of a potent effect there are
some reasons for that
um and of course we dissuade people from
ingesting caffeine too late in the day
because it'll disrupt sleep so I'm not
saying fast for three hours then drink
caffeine but who knows maybe that's in
your protocol the simple version of this
question is what are your thoughts on
training fasted and if people are going
to train fasted how should they modulate
their fluid intake if at all what
happens with exercise in the endurance
and Metabolism episode we walk through
and the fact that no matter what you're
using for fuel carbohydrates or fat or
even other potential sources the end
product of all of those is ATP CO2 and
water
right so you're trying to make ATP that
is the fuel for exercise now ATP is
adenosine triphosphate so one two three
phosphates on top of an adenosine well
what you may have not put together
is if you
hydrolyze ATP and you break off one of
those phosphates you now have ADP if you
do it again you have amp addressing
monophosphide if you do it one more time
now you just have adenosine
and if you have then therefore run
through a lot of exercise
burned a lot of energy you have
increased the amount of adenosine that's
floating around
now if you have a high concentration of
adenosine what's that going to make you
want to do
that's going to bind to certain
receptors and we know when those
receptors get bound to you fall asleep
bingo caffeine
will competitively bind to those
receptors therefore that's why caffeine
stops you
from feeling like you want to go to
sleep right so we have a very clear
relationship between exercise fuel in
fact if you look at the literature
there's a pretty clear relationship
between the more caloric expenditure in
different sports and the higher amount
of hours needed for sleep so there's a
nice tie between how hard you're
exercising how much energy you're
burning how much you need to sleep
stimulants which brings us all the way
back to your question of fueling
so do I need a fuel prior to my exercise
about if you're going to be limited in
your exercise bout buy fuel
then fueling is necessary one way or the
other if it is a type of training that
is not then it's not going to matter and
so the examples we gave if you're doing
if you're going to go do a 30-second
bout of maximal exertion and you're
going to do it one time
you don't need to worry about fueling at
all we're eating within your workout
because it's only 30 seconds yeah you
got 30 seconds you don't need to worry
about hydration post exercise you don't
need to worry about recovery total
energy expenditure was nothing if you're
going to go
um you know you're going to go practice
you're going to go to the driving range
and practice your golf swing you don't
need to worry about it the total amount
of energy expenditure is just not high
in fact in that case you might want to
keep it somewhat low because you want to
keep blood glucose fairly even and you
don't want to bring into the system you
certainly wouldn't want to use
stimulants right because you may get
over exerted inside
in all of these things we probably
should have started off our conversation
with this
in terms of macronutrients
the total amount throughout the day
is more important generally
than the timing of them which is why you
can do things like have a bunch of
carbohydrate at night not eat the next
morning and lift and be just fine it
doesn't matter that you didn't have them
in a few hours before your muscle
glycogen is topped off your liver is
glycogen is topped off you're absolutely
fine you have plenty of fuel even if
you're to wait a few more hours in fact
even if you were to do conditioning
you're probably fine I I have plenty of
athletes that prefer to do many of their
training sessions faster in the morning
for personal reasons not because it
enhances performance but if it doesn't
enhance or harm it then and it's a
personal preference thing fine
if you're going to go do a session
though where you're going to be really
concerned with muscle glycogen depletion
and again you can go back that episode
to learn of different types when those
thresholds hits and what you worry about
then a feeling would be important you
would either need to have something
before the session or consume it during
the session so one of the other things
we'd like to say here is recovery
starts
during the previous workout
right so if you're working out right now
and you optimize nutrition right now
even if you don't necessarily need it
for the current workout if you can get
ahead on recovery then you're going to
be fine the next day and the
differentiation here between
carbohydrate and protein is important so
the total amount of protein you ingest
throughout the day is probably a bigger
determinant for things like muscle
growth than the timing so the post
exercise anabolic window it doesn't
necessarily matter carbohydrate is
different the timing of that does matter
it needs to be around and available
you can maximize both hydration
and muscle glycogen resynthesis which is
restoring the muscle glycogen you burn
during exercise I also work with
athletes that train multiple times a day
so in those particular cases
a recovery window is half what you
normally have so if you're in a
situation where you have two or three
days before you work out again you don't
need to worry about getting carbohydrate
in before during or after Because by the
time you go to train again you will have
restored your muscle glycogen levels
easily however if you're training every
day or twice in a day then the timing of
carbohydrate really starts to matter in
that case I see no reason to not ingest
those nutrients either before during or
after you don't need to necessarily do
it but you can
the general rule of thumb I give is
something like this
if you're doing something where you're
trying to really work hard whether this
is hypertrophy training or a lot of
endurance energy expenditure is going to
be high potential muscle damage is high
and or energy
utilization is high
what you want to look for is a number
something in the area of like half a
gram of carbohydrate
per pound of body weight
so you weigh 200 pounds you want to make
sure that either pre-mid or post or
total
you bring in 100 grams of carbohydrate
it's just a very rough number to start
protein is about half of that
so it's about a quarter of your body
weight
right so those numbers would be if
you're 200 pounds make sure you have 100
grams of carbs and 50 grams of protein
and again it doesn't necessarily have to
be before or during or after
and you'll be in a good spot all you
need to do then
is Alter what I do I should say is Alter
the amount of carbohydrate
based on energy expenditure
so a lower energy and easier workout
instead of having 100 grams of carbs I
might tack that down to 75 or even 50
and be it a one to one carb protein
ratio if it was even harder more sun
hotter outside more fluid loss I might
go from 100 grams of carbs up to 150 or
200 and get closer to like a three to
one or four to one carbohydrate to
protein ratio so those are the numbers
that I generally go by well as I take a
sip of My Double Espresso Americano here
I'd love for you to tell us about
stimulants sure there's no shortage of
these in most of our lives and of course
you can cover the health benefits of it
later you maybe you have an episode yes
we have an episode on caffeine and it
does have certain health benefits
although one has to use caffeine
correctly in order to drive those yeah
so there's caffeine is the easy one to
start with and we won't belabor the
point here uh the evidence is strong it
has a negrogenic effect you can take it
at whatever dosage is reasonable for you
and of course there is a bit of a
learning curve there such that obviously
the more you take it the more you need
to take even though there's actually
some recent evidence showing even folks
who are acclimated to it will still see
an ergogenic benefit even though if they
don't feel a big boost of this so
typically that takes 30 to 45 minutes or
so but it's highly dependent upon the
person so some people can smell coffee
and immediately feel better and that's
probably working actually through a
different mechanism
of anticipation but you can take it
there the half-life of it is you know
four to six hours or something like that
it totally depends on the person so
don't let it ruin your sleep but if you
take it prior to Performance it has a
noticeable effect on particularly
endurance maximum strength may be less
well quite clearly less so in fact the
data are mixed there on whether it
actually does anything for Peak strength
although I think most people would
uh Rec would suggest that you know
you're going to take it prior to trying
to truly lift as high as trying to you
know lift a one repetition Max or
similar but most of the the documented
effects are on the the endurance based
activities yes so my read of the
literature uh in terms of performance
enhancing effects of caffeine are that
one to three milligrams I want to make
sure that people hear the units
correctly before people Blitz themselves
out with that caffeine one to three
milligrams per kilogram of body weight
about 30 minutes prior to exercise
has a definite performance enhancing
effect it also has a definite mental
performance enhancing effect especially
when people who are regular caffeine
users have abstained from caffeine for
anywhere from 2 to 15 days and and
that's an extremely rare circumstance
but even if they have not it appears
that one to three milligrams per
kilogram of body weight of caffeine
taken about again it's not super precise
as far as I can see now about 30 minutes
before the event starts
um
can really enhance reaction time and
power output and as well as as you
mentioned endurance when I was
researching the caffeine episode one
interesting caveat that
um I discovered was that if people are
not caffeine adapted they are not
regular users of caffeine the sudden
introduction of caffeine
can really degrade performance mostly
because people don't know how to operate
at that high level of autonomic arousal
have you ever observed that yeah 100 in
fact there's actually data going up as
high as 10 milligrams per kilogram of
body weight wow which is in fact once
you cross the five milligram per
kilogram threshold you will start seeing
performance decrements so there's
absolutely such a thing of ruining your
performance with too much caffeine so
most people listening to this if you're
thinking wow they said caffeine I'm all
in and then you just stop listening and
now you you know go for your quad
espresso shot before your every time you
go to work out you probably are passing
that threshold if you think about those
numbers one to three milligrams per
kilogram body weight if you weigh 100
kilograms that's 220 pounds that'd be
something like two to five hundred
milligrams of caffeine which is like a
pretty high amount but you know a coffee
is going to get you close and espresso
is going to get you somewhat in that
ballpark depending on source and stuff
um so you don't really need to go and
blister your brain with caffeine in fact
if you do is it's quite common and in
fact likely that you'll actually make
performance worse right yeah the amount
of caffeine in different
coffees and sodas Etc of course varies
one thing that people ought to know is
that the smallest of commercially
available
um coffees at the most popular
commercial vendor so
um
generally contain anywhere from 250 to
350 milligrams of caffeine what that
means is that the so-called medium and
the large contain as much as 500
milligrams or one gram of caffeine so
for you morning large coffee at a
commercial vendor
drinkers if you're wondering why you get
a headache if you're 30 minutes late on
that caffeine or
um if you can't access that caffeine at
all or even if you're drinking coffee
excuse me from another source you're
finding like oh it's really not doing it
for me it's because the amount of
caffeine in the now commercially sold uh
coffees is exceedingly high it's about
two or three times higher than the
standard lookup tables that you'll see
on the internet so I'm not saying that
to demonize caffeine we can pretty
quickly adapt to and form a tolerance to
caffeine some people never really can
get over the Jitters other people
um are just fine with even a thousand
milligrams of caffeine but only because
they've been drinking a lot of caffeine
consistently anyway it's also wildly
inconsistent from location to location
uh The Brew type the functionality so
yeah that stuff can be very hard to
figure out what's happening there's only
one way really to uh objectively measure
caffeine and that's use caffeine tablets
and they work pretty well actually uh
someone I know who's prominent in the
podcast space uses 100 to 200 milligrams
of caffeine in tablet form combined with
tea so they've now conditioned
themselves to think that herbal tea
actually has this caffeinating effect
but um tablet form caffeine while I'm
not recommending it to to outright it is
going to give you the best sense of how
much caffeine you can tolerate and how
much is performance enhancing or is
performance degrading there's actually
another line of supplementation we can
go down here which is not technically a
stimulant but it's something I use to
help performance
when you don't want caffeine and so this
thing specifically if you're one of
those folks who have to exercise at
night
and you want a little bit of boost for
your training but you don't want to have
caffeine because it messes up your sleep
and this is when you can turn to the
whole like citrulline Arginine nitric
oxide sort of route and we'll skip the
explanation there but effectively what
happens is nitric oxide is this
wonderful compound that causes
vasodilation and of course that's going
to Aid then in transporting nutrients in
and out of the cell so it has an
ergogenic effect the you have a number
of ways you can go about this some of
them have
more pros and cons than others and and
there are more and more data coming out
specifically on citrulline more recently
if you look though in my opinion the
most consistent evidence for the most
consistent effect is in the supplement
of beetroot or beetroot juice or extract
or something like that so you can find
those supplements and they tend to again
they're pretty effective and enhancing
performs specifically anything moderate
to longer duration endurance performance
and they are not a stimulant so they
won't ruin your sleep that much you know
one note of caution for those of you
that are interested in citrulline or
beetroot because they are in the
Arginine pathway if you're somebody who
has a predisposition to cold sores
um oral cold sores that is or other
forms of cold sores that
um because activation of the Arginine
pathway can exacerbate some of the
neural related aspects of cold sores and
that's because the viruses that cause
those cold sores actually live on
neurons then you want to be very
cautious with citrulline especially high
dose citrulline I can really amplify
that the cold sore response what about
non-stimulant yet
um
Focus enhancing supplements things like
Alpha GPC for example I routinely use
300 to 600 milligrams of alpha GPC prior
to hard physical training typically
weight training but occasionally I'll
take 300 milligrams of alpha GPC prior
to a mental work bout less often these
days because I kind of reserve it for
physical training and I don't tend to
use it every day maybe once every you
know third or fourth workout combined
with caffeine so that combination is
pretty uh pretty potent I find and so
technically because it's a cholinergic
Agonist it's not a stimulant in the
traditional sense but it has a focusing
and an alertness promoting aspect to it
what are your thoughts on those sorts of
compounds there's not much human perform
exercise performance data on those there
are certainly cognitive
functioning tests on those so you're not
going to find a lot of information no
though there isn't none we actually will
use many of these substances you could
globally call them nootropics which is
you know any
substance that specifically only has
brain function is a rough way to think
about it we'll use them prior to
more challenging bouts of training this
is something that we'll pull out say on
sparring day only
or the most important training session
or a session when you're trying to work
on Pitch command or when you're trying
to enhance work on your shot and as a
basketball player or you're really
trying to improve a certain swing as a
golfer or something like that but we do
not use them every day we do not use
them with every person so yeah we will
use those they are not stimulants but
they can be performance enhancing and
another kind of way to think about this
is if you're in the case of
caloric restriction so whether you're
trying to lose weight or we're actually
trying to control weight for you know
weight purposes in terms of a sports
where you have to be in a certain weight
class or something like that
well we may not be able to give you food
in fact we may not be able to give you
stimulants because of the sleep thing or
because we're already like maxed on a
sibilance
now we can go this route and so at least
like mentally you're a little bit there
and you're more likely to be alert and
focused and you can train harder despite
the fact that we didn't actually change
fuel now that's a little bit of a short
game in terms of that's not your
permanent solution you eventually need
to bring calories up or you know
whatever other trains you're training or
whatever we're going to do but it can
work in a nice short pinch I'm very
interested to learn from you about
fatigue reducers and I'm hoping that
rhodiola rosea will come up in the
conversation yeah great let's just start
right there then there's actually a lot
of research on this despite most people
not having heard of it I think I
mentioned in a previous episode I've
used it a lot over many many years
you have to be a little bit careful of
it there's well first of all no we only
we should have said this at the onset no
supplement is the Panacea right
nothing's going to work for everything
in Rodeo is no no different it can have
a number of effects if you look across
the literature you're going to find
generally somewhere between a small
benefit to little benefit it but not
often is it detrimental with a few
exceptions I know of a handful of papers
that would be two specifically where it
may actually reduce muscular endurance
okay fine if you think about what's
happening is one of the benefits that
has been seen so far with Rhodiola
is it is helpful at managing cortisol
but cortisol suppression is not a
necessarily a good thing we talked about
how if you do an acute out of stress
cortisol will go way up and that is a
sign of acute stress however a sign of
long-term excessive stress is cortisol
suppression and so this is a thing to be
really careful of is if you're feeling
down or lethargic or tired and you think
your adrenals are messed up and then you
start taking cortisol modulators you
could be making the problem worse
because now your cortisol is actually
suppressed and now you're taking these
things to blunt it or keep it low and
then you continue to feel lethargic and
lack of desire and libido and focus and
sort of all these things so cortisol is
not a bad thing we want this to be going
up and down
uh
any amounts that we want so if we're
thinking about like for example waking
up
um you would want generally something
like a 50 reduction in the first hour in
terms of cortisol concentrations however
if you're extremely suppressed already
um going down is is only going to be a
problem so rhodiola is is has a a good
evidence base to support it for that um
you'll see actually a number of studies
that have looked at it in a whole host
of areas for benefits so something good
to do um the difficult part with
rhodiola to be quite honest is getting
it from a high quality brand and Source
it's difficult to get as a single source
which is a very very important thing to
do with supplements to try to get them
sourced alone Rodeo that typically comes
in combination with any other herbals or
other stuff adrenal support etc etc and
also then getting them then third party
certified which for most folks is not
necessary but for any athletes that need
to go through drug testing systems you
should not take any supplement at all
that does not have some sort of
third-party certification so those are
the challenges that being said if you've
ever ran into somebody who's taking
rhodiola and they're like I didn't do
anything for me it it's possible that's
you know nothing works for everyone it
also could be just very poor quality
sourcing so if you look at uh the there
have been a number of papers on
um its perception of fatigue and you've
sort of mentioned that you felt pretty
immediate effects of taking it a few
times yeah I'm fairly sensitive of
supplements but I've started taking uh
rhodiola before
workouts and found that I could push
much harder much longer through the
workout normally I would or typically
before taking it
um that is in sessions where I did not
take it I would be able to work
out very hard for 20 minutes or so the
next 10 minutes I could get some work
output and then the remaining uh period
of time it was kind of a tapering off
now granted these are very intense
training sessions these are not the
endurance training sessions these are
the weight training sessions that one
one time per week per body part type
sessions uh what I've noticed is I can
complete the entire 60 minutes with with
minimal fatigue now I mean obviously I
hit fatigues within sets and of course
you know I get you remain human despite
taking it but um I found to be very
useful and I've been using it whenever I
use Alpha GPC prior to workouts yeah and
I've been impressed by
by it overall I do want to highlight
something that you said because I think
it's so so vitally important which is
that using single ingredient
formulations for most things is critical
to figuring out what works for you what
doesn't what dosages you need being able
to take things uh two on one off
um two days on one day off for instance
being able to increase dosage in the
morning and then maybe reduce the dosage
and combine with something else in the
afternoon
single ingredient formulations are
pretty much the only way to do that
there's perhaps only one supplement that
I take at all and that's athletic greens
is there have been a regular podcast
sponsor for a long time that is a
cocktail of many many things and those
are all adaptogens as well as some
probiotics and vitamins and things like
that so I'm not opposed to Blends where
the Blends include a lot of nutrients
that are synergistic but for all pill
capsule
based supplements where I'm looking for
a very targeted effect and it's not just
about foundational nutrition I
really believe strongly that single
ingredient formulations are the way that
you can build a rational approach to
supplementation and also make
adjustments if something isn't making
you feel better and also make
adjustments if something's really
working for you so for instance some
people might take Alpha GPC 300
milligrams and not feel anything go up
to 600 milligrams not feel anything
maybe just feel kind of they don't like
it other people like myself took 300
milligrams of alpha GPC the first time I
was like wow this really puts me in the
zone
but I want to be really careful how
often I use it I did mention I go up to
600 milligrams occasionally but that
really puts me on the outer threshold of
kind of overall levels of focus and
amped up such that if I drink too much
caffeine it can tilt me over the edge so
I encourage people to become scientists
of themselves and the only way to do
that is to try and limit the number of
variables and the final point is that I
think that single ingredient
formulations are by far the best in
terms of
changing things over time you know this
could be um uh women during their
menstrual cycle might find that during
certain phases of the cycle they're more
sensitive to certain things than not
others and for men and women it may be
that you know certain times of year even
and uh certain supplements might go
better closer to sleep some earlier in
the day and on and on and on there's
just no real way in my opinion to have a
supplementation protocol that involves
lots and lots of Blends one or two
Blends okay but lots of Blends I think
that's um I actually think that's the
potentially dangerous territory yeah I
mean just take rhodiola as a good
example I know a new meta-analysis came
out just in the last few months looking
at it and they found in general you see
again a slight to moderate Improvement
and everything from Power output to
fatigue resistant antioxidant effects to
endurance performance so it's like okay
great maybe there's a little bit here
now let's say you went to do it and the
only way you could access rhodiola is in
common Nation with that and some lion's
mane and you know some other of these
adaptogens and was like well wait a
minute I just wanted to take this to get
a better workout but now it also came
with the stimulant or this cortisol
suppressor or cortisol activator well
now also you can't take it at night or
you can't take it in the morning because
you're already you already had coffee
your options are just way limited so I
think the biggest part of all that is
you if something doesn't feel good you
have absolutely no idea you don't know
if it was a rollio you don't know if it
was the boswellian it is in there you
don't know if it was any of the other
things that were smashed in there or it
could be something as simple as the
um the the citric acid they use like
some other combination of thing and now
here you are thinking that some
supplement that actually works for you
doesn't and you throw that out of your
repertoire for the rest of your life
which is
you know not the biggest crime but it's
not needed and you're not really going
to know so yeah I fully stamped you can
look back at my course lectures for the
last decade and you will see like
stamped number one on the supplement the
sections is make sure you're taking
single ingredient supplements at all
costs
the last part about that too is you're
more likely
to ensure the amount that is on the
label is correct so if you're taking
rhodiola and it says you know it's 100
milligrams in there and if that's only
thing that's in there you're more likely
than not to actually get something close
now they're never perfect but it will be
close if it's in a combination of 20
other things you actually don't have any
idea if that's in there in fact there
have been many papers on melatonin
and vitamin D
and a number of other supplements in
which when you actually just pull them
off the shelf these are these are
standard studies where they would go and
buy us in like 20 to 25 different
supplements in the case of melatonin and
we'll actually measure the amount of
melatonin actually in them and despite
the fact that the label says five
milligrams they can be up to a 500 to a
thousand fold actual concentration in
that supplement and then you wonder why
some people react great to melatonin and
some people that absolutely destroys you
and this is also why like we'll actually
we'll see this constantly well people
will have like 500 times the upper limit
of melatonin the morning after
when the half-life is supposed to be
more like 90 minutes it should be
totally gone but we're seeing extremely
high I'm not even talking like double
I'm talking 10 20 30X the upper limit
range for melatonin the next morning and
then it's like well what are you taking
he's like oh I got this melatonin at X
store or X website and you're like holy
cow
um so I'm not opposed to melatonin
theoretically
um but you have to be careful with that
one in particular so any supplement has
that to be true
so you want to buy them from
as many places as you can that are high
quality and if they are third party
tested even if you're not a performance
athlete
I want to stress this even if you're not
a performance athlete third party
certified and tested supplements are
you're less likely to just just get
wildly high concentrations or low
concentrations of active ingredients and
so relative to other ones who you might
get for cheaper but you could be totally
wrecking Yourself by getting you know 50
milligrams of melatonin every night and
not realizing it so then of course the
next morning you drown yourself in
caffeine and then you can see what death
cycle you're in now yeah and people
could look for third party certification
on the packaging and um some websites
will allow you to zoom in on the bottle
beforehand it's largely listed on on
certain vendor websites a brief point
about supplement cost and blends and I
promise this will be a brief point
different ingredients meaning different
types of supplements have widely varying
costs in order to you know create to get
them to manufacture them so often does
what you'll find is that blends will um
include the least amount of the most
expensive
uh ingredient right um not always the
case there are some there are certain
exceptions to this and I mentioned some
Blends that I like a few minutes ago
that are for foundational nutrition
adaptogens and probiotics athletic
greens of course just being one of
several examples out there but when it
comes to say a sleep Blend or a
pre-workout blend there are some decent
products out there but a lot of them
tend to put in more of the
least expensive ingredients and less of
the ones that you're actively seeking
and so those tend to be caffeine tends
to be a kind of a buffer against the
other things meaning if you pre-workout
that putting caffeine in there isn't
necessarily a bad thing but if it has
five other things in there oftentimes
what manufacturers will cheat on is the
actual amount of the things that are
costly so again single ingredient
formulations for eighty percent of your
supplements I think is really the way to
go and the other thing I know is going
to come up as we're talking about all
these supplements is this issue of
dependency I often get this question and
when I solicit for questions uh on
social media in anticipation of this
episode number of people said okay so if
you take a sleep formulation do I need
to take it every night if I don't take
it will I have an incredibly hard time
sleeping if I take a pre-workout every
time I train will uh will I need it it's
a great question some people will take
supplement holidays as they may be
called for a couple of days each week
back back to back some people take them
straight through I myself take a sleep
cocktail we've described this it's
magnesium theanine and things this is
not one ingredient these are multiple
ingredients in fact precisely because
some people who have sleep walking and
Vivid dream issues can't take theanine
before bed in any case I've had times
when I either forgot my supplements
that's rare or I just didn't have what I
needed or just simply took a break for a
night and it was not a problem
but in terms of pre-workout I do think
that people become dependent on being in
that really ramped up state but I don't
think we view all this as like true
dependency kind of like addiction
totally right I mean I Define addiction
as a progressive narrowing of the things
that bring you pleasure so you know I I
suppose people could get addicted to
pre-workout but it seems a little
unlikely more likely there would be a
dependency such that if you didn't have
your pre-workout you might feel like oh
you're not motivated to train so what
are your thoughts on
um taking little holidays from
supplements and varying the frequency of
supplement and in particular as it
relates to stimulants and fatigue
reducers the end goal
anytime I coach somebody is to get them
into a physiological state in which they
require
no or close to no supplementation
that's the target we should
really be in a position to where our
lifestyle our sunlight exposure our
Stress Management our physical activity
our sleep and our hydration and our
whole food nutrition provide us almost
everything we need now look again there
are some foundational items that we can
give people we've put together a little
bundle actually for this that the basic
things that you can go look at
but that's the goal right so the target
is to be let your physiology run the guy
your physiology is way smarter than we
are even if I take a bunch of biomarkers
from you your physiology still knows
better than those few markers can tell
me so that's always where we're ending
up I actually personally
don't like people being in a position
that they have to take a supplement for
anything so I don't like it if you have
to take a supplement to have a good
night of sleep I don't like it if you
have to have a supplement to train we
will use any of these stimulants very
very carefully
with any of the athletes we work with
and certainly for the non-athletes
because at least the athletes we have an
end date we have a fight schedule we
have a season we have a game you're
going to pitch whatever
when you don't have that it's sort of
like you're in this endless cycle of oh
you're just going to do that all day
every day
um we don't really need to be in that
spot
so what I the way that I describe My
Philosophy is I will use those
short-term tactics
to symptom manage if I have to so if
somebody comes to me and like you're
feeling awful and we've got to get
through the hump okay great maybe we'll
give you something for Sleep immediately
to get you sleeping that allows us to
then come back and work on the causal
problem right so this is what is why are
you having a hard time sleeping anyways
if you have to take a nine cocktail
supplement to sleep then all we're doing
is is blinding the reason why are you in
that position to begin with right so we
see this all the time whether it is
sleep problems whether it's cortisol or
testosterone the question is well why is
that low now we may give you something
again to manage it immediately but the
task the the mystery I'm going to try to
unveil is why why is it there to begin
with this could be something like this
is natural for you and your lack of
energy is something else
or it could be actually it is not a
natural level for you but something is
suppressing it any number of you've got
some infection going on there's some
allergic reaction to something in your
environment there's a you know mold
Mercury like that one comes up a lot
you'll see Mercury and folks and that's
causing a lot of problems um or any
number of heavy metals or toxins any
host of things psychological distress
bad daily habit you don't ever see the
sun like you don't ever sweat you don't
ever drink we was talking about so many
things so I'm always going to hunt
for that and I hate using this phrase
it's highly maligned for a good reason
but root cause all right so we're trying
to find that it's like are we making
sure that we're not causing this problem
and I'm not going to want to give you a
supplement
to cover up something if we're not even
trying to solve the problem of what's
being there that being said am I that
concerned about people taking a
multivitamin just all throughout no not
really am I concerned about people
taking creatine no like go ahead those
ones are generally pretty fine to to
just take but anything else I want a
reason
I really don't like giving people
anything in a super physiological
concentration or a superfood
concentration right so again an amount
you wouldn't find in a normal food
dosage unless we have really a specific
reason some of these things are more
problematic
others are less problematic so when an
ant to answer the question of dependency
you have a combination of actual
physiological dependency caffeine like
that actually creates a physiological
dependency versus a emotional or
psychological dependency or just a I
like drinking this like that's my habit
that's my routine there's a fancy
scientific phrase for that but it
doesn't matter so yeah we want to get
off that and like again my personal
philosophy is I don't want you dependent
upon anything I want to create extremely
resilient people and I want to create
physiological resilience we actually
have a fancy little algorithm we use to
measure that in people and so we can
actually calculate that number and the
goal of us is to push that number higher
so that we don't have to have anything
so many situations pop up in your real
life
that you're not going to have your
supplements or you're not going to have
your routine or you're not going to have
your journal or whatever
but also for the long term I don't want
to create a situation in which this is a
short-term success that you have to now
do that the rest of your life
no let's just get out of the way let's
fix the problem if there is something
symptom management that's real
while we're actually searching for a
better foundational habits um the last
thing I want to say about this is
if you're only covering symptom
you're really missing signal right which
is if you're constantly tired throughout
the day and all you're doing is giving
yourself a number of Alpha gpcs and
caffeines Etc even though there's good
literature okay are you really just
using that to allow your poor sleep
hygiene to happen if I took those away I
bet you
you would actually start addressing your
sleep if that's the Cause right all
right you're stress or your poor
hydration like you would go hunting for
the problem
and so like you want to walk a fine line
here of going like Hey look is an
athletic greens supplement that big a
deal no probably not but
wait a minute am I actually now covering
up the pain point
that is maybe needed it's a signal to
actually get my ass in gear to go make
one of these changes
um whatever it needs to be so I know I
got like a little bit meta on you a
little bit philosophical but that's
honestly how I approach it yeah I think
it's really important a friend of mine
who's a physician has a great saying um
which is Better Living Through Chemistry
still requires Better Living oh um
that's golden that's so good you know
and it pertains also to things like
antidepressants and ADHD drugs and
things of that sort most all of those
things were developed as tools to allow
people to move from a maladaptive State
okay maladaptive it's hard to Define but
think about in any domain of life you
can either be back on your heels
flat-footed or forward Center of mass
and there are times when people are so
compromised neurochemically that they
need to use pharmacology in order to get
into a flat-footed position yeah you
know they're really back on their heels
flat footed or forward Center or mass
but the idea was always that those
things were developed as things to allow
people to engage in the sorts of
behaviors that can produce the same
sorts of neurochemical shifts and if
people are thinking well what sorts of
behaviors can induce these neurochemical
shifts I'll just zoom out myself for a
moment here and say I am a big proponent
I believe you are as well if I may
in doing behavioral tools first whenever
possible really establishing good habits
the do's and don'ts which we've talked a
lot about in this series and in this
episode
then excellent nutrition which involves
do's and don'ts volume food Choice
timing all the factors and then also
supplementation
and also they're sometimes a case for
prescription drugs certainly and often
brain machine interface or body machine
interface measuring stuff using devices
but that the foundation of behaviors and
good nutrition are really truly
foundational and it's hard in anything
to skip steps but supplements and
prescription drugs are one place where
people often skip steps and then they
they don't actually learn how to
cultivate the best behavioral practices
including the don'ts as you mentioned
and then just one more point along these
lines
you know you talked about taking
anything for energy is really uh
disruptive to the system and it is
because especially caffeine while it has
its uses and even health benefits it's
really borrowing it it's against the
adenosine system with interest and so
because caffeine acts as an adenosine
antagonist effectively while caffeine is
present in those receptors you don't
feel as sleepy you have more energy your
reaction time goes down memories enhance
Focus performance of all kinds yes but
then when that caffeine is dislodged
from the receptor then the adenosine can
act even more potently at those
receptors so it's sort of like being
able to borrow against the normal
variations in wakefulness and sleep and
this is why we encourage people if
they're not training first thing in the
morning to push their caffeine intake
out about 90 to 120 minutes after waking
so they can clear some of that adenosine
in the morning which tends to happen
even
after we wake up
um people can listen to episodes on
Master your sleep or perfect sleep for
the caffeine episode to understand more
about that but the the final thing I
just want to say here and then it
prompts a question is you know in
thinking about
supplement protocols
I think a lot of people assume that once
they start taking something they're
going to have to take it all the time
and one idea perhaps is that people have
some Alpha GPC around that they could
take and granted it'd be great if people
could try things without having to buy a
whole product I think companies
hopefully are listening to this and
we'll give people a sample to see if
something works for them and then give
them an opportunity to try it to have
things around but not necessarily assume
you're going to take it every time right
some things you take every day
foundational nutrition
supplements for instance but then also
to take a look at how well you're eating
or not eating right at times when I'm
eating much better I consuming you know
low sugar fermented foods which are
great for the gut microbiome I consume
less probiotics if ever I've been really
compromised for whatever reason then I
will take pill form probiotics but I
don't take those all the time because I
get them from food and from certain you
know Green strings like athletic greens
and so forth so I think that nutrition
and supplement are tethered in this way
in my mind and I don't think that most
people think of supplementation as
something that where you can induce a
lot of variability in when and how you
take them but as far as I'm concerned as
long as they're single ingredient
formulations you can be
um you can use supplements once a week
if you want you can use them seven days
a week you could use them twice a day
four times a day every day
or you could use them not at all agreed
yeah some of them will have an effect
randomly like that others will not and
we talked about creating being one of
them it's if you're going to take it
once or so a week then there's I mean
basically no benefit that's a very good
point creatine
um beta alanine
is another fantastic example of
something you need to take consistently
if you want some sort of benefit
it needs to be built up in muscle we
need to use that to create uh carnosine
which is what's actually going to help
us with our fatigue management that's
why we call it like an acid buffer so in
our previous metabolism episode we
talked about that being a major cause of
fatigue the wonderful part the one of
the reasons why beta alanine works so
effectively is it blocks that buildup so
that is an example of another one that
you would want to take other things like
fish oil
you could certainly skip a day here and
there it wouldn't be that big a deal I
also do support your comment if you can
take absolutely none of these things and
and be just fine
um in terms of and we'll come back maybe
to Beta alanine in a second
in terms of some other fun stuff my
colleague Greg osiki ran a really cool
number of studies looking at how
exercise actually Alters the microbiome
this is actually an area that we I
probably have 300 stool samples sitting
in my freezer in my lab oh goodness
another reason to pause before entering
your lab yeah another reason to not
apply to come be one of my graduate
students unless you want to deal with
that we actually have a number we've
applied for a couple of Grants to look
more into this specifically with females
so hopefully we can get that funded but
nonetheless
you can actually see some a pretty
traumatic and I say that word on purpose
changes in the gut microbiome there's
one in particular study I was thinking
of that Greg did is he looked at the the
changes pre-post and ultra marathon
and even within a single bot of exercise
I can't remember some of the markers but
I know one of the markers was
specifically increased by like 14 000
percent
uh after a single bout of exercise now
this is an ultra marathon this is like
like totally absurd amount of exercise
relative to what normal people would do
would be but that number I remember like
it was like fourteen thousand two
hundred twenty nine percent or like
something some random number like that
of something meaningful yeah something
meaningful I can't remember which marker
uh that was that had changed um I know
streptococcus was in there streptococcus
went up like maybe something more like
30 or 40 or 50 so the point is
we haven't even had the proper time and
we don't to even launch into the
microbiome supplementation there needs
to be ultra specific you wouldn't be
best served to just jump in and take
random things there
um that's it's a whole area of emerging
science we know very very very little
about it but there is a number of
actionable things one could do there so
probably something to not mess with uh
would certainly work with a qualified
physician if you think you have
something going on clinical or
you know some actual problem there don't
work with someone who's not a specialist
a medical doctor there but just randomly
assigning a bunch of probiotics or
prebiotics without intention is Maybe
the next Forefront of human performance
research but we'll have to maybe come
back in a few years and dive into that
in detail or perhaps you can bring
somebody out as an expert in that to
discuss that yeah gut microbiome is
fascinating I think of sleep as the most
powerful performance enhancing
activity uh of course you still have to
do the activity yeah I consider it
foundational like it basically raises
the tide on mental health physical
health performance of all kinds
um there's recent data that during sleep
your body goes through all its various
forms of metabolism possible yep which
is amazing this was measured from breath
in human subjects breath metabolites in
human subjects so obviously uh if one is
thinking about supplementation and
wondering okay what's what's the best
supplement to enhance performance you
gave some great rationale for why
creatine would be an excellent choice
provided to your eating well and
hydrating well and then to my mind the
next thing on the list would be anything
that allows you to improve the
quality and maybe even the duration of
your sleep although if you wake up and
you feel rested throughout the day and
only need a short nap in the afternoon
not everyone needs one but then
generally that means you're feeling okay
people sometimes get flipped onto this
idea that they have insomnia insomnia is
excessive daytime sleepiness where
you're falling asleep during the day
that's insomnia it could also be
narcolepsy but that's insomnia but
supplementation to improve the quality
or duration of sleep or both
seems to me like the most direct route
even though actually technically it's an
indirect route to to Performance
enhancement and then thinking about
things that increase alertness and
stimulants and fatigue reducers do you
think that's a good logic yeah we go to
absurd lengths
to dial sleep in as much as we can I
mean the honest answer is like truly
absurd this is a conflict of interest
that my company I'm a part of this
absolute rest is anyone that company we
actually go out to your house
and run a full clinical grade sleep
study in you your bedroom on you and run
that over multiple nights so instead of
having to go to a Sleep Clinic and have
it done in this weird hospital room or
sort of setting with these people
looking at you through a mirror it's
like totally creepy
um that is important because that's the
only way to truly determine how you are
sleeping now that said the technology of
wearable trackers is getting better in
fact I would actually predict those
things will reach a level of accuracy
equivalent to the PSG in the next couple
of years and probably will get FDA
approval to be able to diagnose
officially Sleep Disorders
um that's my total my prediction from
some inside information I don't know
that to be true but it is getting a lot
better right now those wearables are not
accurate enough to meet that threshold
so the we do is we bring up basically
all the equipment to do that so we'll
come in and do that now once we
understand exactly how you're sleeping
the next question is to answer why are
you sleeping that way and so this is a
full four-fold system number one is
we're going to look at biology which
means you're going to take saliva and
blood
and we're looking at everything from
neurotransmitters concentrations to
vitamins B6 B12 Etc that are important
for Sleep performance so we're going to
see is that is it a physiological
problem is there something happening
there is cortisol DHEA ratio that we've
previously talked about or is something
like that off
if it's not physiology then we're going
on the next one which is environmental
we run a full environmental scan of your
bedroom during those nights of sleep
that were there and that's really
important because we can look at
everything from dander and pollen and
allergens that are in the air a quick
tip here is wash your sheets at least
once a week one of the common most
common places that people get allergens
in the air is actually from accumulation
on your sheets so if you clean those
more often you'll be in a better spot
and next one the next one there also is
like keep your I'm sorry this hurts my
heart I don't even I
in in truthfulness I violate this but
keep your pets out of your bedroom and
certainly keep them off your bed
our Ghost Face Killer is my dog and
milky is my other one they don't go on
my bed but they're right next to my bed
so we violate that one but full
environmental scan includes all those
things of course there's we measure
light and temperature and humidity and
everything else that's going on in the
room
um volatile Organics that are coming out
of the mattress formaldehyde lead out of
the wall like all these things that
could potentially disrupt your sleep and
we want to make sure that none of those
things are kicking on uh we see this
constantly people will have things like
trying to be cool and they want to be
cold at night because that's important
and so they'll turn an air conditioner
on or a fan but the air conditioner
kicking on and off at night actually can
shoot you out of various sleep stations
so you want to be really careful about
it's going the last metric on that is
actually CO2
and so what you remember from our
metabolism discussion is when you exhale
you're breathing out CO2 well if your
room is closed and the ventilation isn't
great the amount of CO2 in your room
starts to build up and we actually very
specifically know the threshold based on
information collected from the
International Space Station actually we
know the Threshold at which CO2 crosses
and starts disrupting sleep so we want
to make sure that you're not sitting in
this CO2 bath in front of your face and
then breathing it back in and disrupting
your sleep so environment is the second
one the third one
is actually now psychology so
um one of the members on our team is a
Harvard MD in Psychiatry and put
together an entire sleep scan survey so
we run through all that to see if
there's anxiety depression anything like
that psychologically going on and then
the first fourth one there is if you
have some sort of actual sleep pathology
and so this again will include some eye
tracking stuff that we can use so we
take all those data they go back to our
team uh we work in combination with with
Steve Locke from Harvard who's done a
ton of stuff he actually set up a lot of
the Circadian rhythm stuff in the
National Space Station as well uh
himself Jeffrey Drummer and MD PhD Etc
and all these folks in a room go over
your data
identify what's going on then build
action plans off of that occasionally
those action plans will include
supplementation but only if necessary
we're really going to try to come back
and work through a system to improve the
Sleep however is needed so I realize
that is not totally accessible
for a lot of people but like if you
really need to go to the end of the
Earth to figure out sleep that service
is available absolute rest sounds like
an amazing tool given that most people
won't be able to use it
um or access it although we will provide
a link in case people are interested in
it and do want to try it
you mentioned a few things that I think
everyone should uh assay their sleeping
environment for and um determine whether
or not they are hindering their sleep
without realizing for instance the air
conditioning going on and off or this
could be heater going on and off or um
central heating or cooling unit
um this could be keeping the room dark
uh this could be cleaning your sheets
certainly that doesn't require
um uh that one sign up for absolute rest
so cleaning one sheets routinely keeping
pets out of the bedroom as you admitted
you don't entirely
um different opinions about that but if
you're having sleep issues the dander
from animals may be part of those issues
and then one that I'll just add which I
think is pretty interesting is there's
some beautiful data out of Michael
turman's Lab at Columbia Medical School
in New York on negative ionization and
this sounds pretty uh wacky kind of new
AGP I'm sure some people like do a
negative ionization but listen the
Turman lab is a serious laboratory focus
on circadian biology for many decades
now negative ion concentrations are
higher near Coastal locations so if
you've ever gone to the sea or gone on
vacation and you sleep better near a
body of water that's actually a real
thing and there are negative ionization
machines but there are also some things
that one can do in order to increase the
negative ion concentration in their
sleeping environment that are nearly
zero cost if not zero cost you can look
those up online and we probably will do
an entire episode about this in the
future but I think what you described
for absolute rest really highlights a
more General set of themes that I think
are really important which is your sleep
environment is an environment it's got a
lot going on in it and it's worth
running through the checklist that you
described and asking you know where
where things you know maybe not
optimized but where am I really getting
in my own way in terms of sleep all of
this again being related to the fact
that getting excellent sleep
consistently is a completely transform
everything that you do and not getting
excellent sleep consistently which is a
challenge for so so many people will
also transform everything that you do
and think and feel but in the negative
Direction yeah I can also offer a few
tips on sleep based on things we find
most consistently for those that can't
go through uh the whole protocol
um one quick little actually app called
time shifter is really cool for anyone
that's dealing with consistent travel
and jet lag so you can go and enter your
location your time where you're going
with the location and then it'll
actually back calculate and it'll give
you full light uh stimulant food
hydration and stuff protocol and you
just follow along with that and we've
used that for many years actually
especially when traveling to like Abu
Dhabi for vice and Mongolia and and
Brazil for the Olympics and sort of all
over the place so that's I think that
app is still available I hope so um it's
great
um a nice tool um a couple of things we
found major if you're dealing with acid
reflux so if you're someone who has
problems like that you can just Elevate
the head of your bed by like six inches
so if you you know put little piece of
wood or something underneath it you can
also buy very inexpensive pillows that
can Elevate that now that's not solving
the problem but at least can help you
sleep whether it's just that night or if
it's a consistent problem you can do
there
um if you're snoring
like I said it's not really benign you
should probably take a look at that your
first step there is mouth tape if that
doesn't work you can go through what's
called myofunctional therapy
um which I don't know if you've covered
that before but it's basically tongue
exercises and that can be quite
effective specifically for people who
have problems with REM sleep so
myofunctional therapy
um it's just a it's kind of like you do
like depending on the protocol uh some
tongue exercises kind of the morning
afternoon or night and that takes a
while to be honest you're probably going
to need at least six weeks before you
start seeing anything but that actually
is is pretty well demonstrated to help
us sleep so you can probably Google we
could find a link for for exact
protocols I don't want to describe all
them but yeah you're going to strengthen
your tongue so that it stops falling in
the back of your neck and waking you up
at night so that's a really free easy
free protocol to use
um if you're struggling with
no it could be insomnia but it could be
just things like when you get into bed
you're super tired and you can't fall
asleep or things like that kind of a
basic rule of thumb we use is only two
things happen in your bed and if you can
make sure those are the only two things
you do in your bed the problems of
falling asleep or insomnia tend to go
down those two things are you have sex
and you sleep and nothing else goes down
in your bed and so you can make that
environment very special and that can
help uh quite effectively improve your
ability to fall asleep and then not wake
up early so keeping that environment
specific to what it's for uh can be
effective
the only other thing I would think of is
and I hate to say this because it's not
super practical but
it's just quite clear at this point
sleeping with a partner in your bed it's
just not very good for sleep so good
luck with that one I know
um you can do a couple of things if it
helps uh you can get two smaller beds
and put them right next to each other if
you can actually have separate sheets
that alone can be helpful
um so if you get I mean if you're on a
king-sized bed or something and again I
know some people they're just like
there's no chance but if you want to
know the cost for your like the
oh my goodness so
um the only last thing I want to mention
here is something that's popped up just
a few times recently but you're going to
see more of uh which is called
orthosomnia
uh so that is a term that is people are
growing concerned over uh which is
wearables and sleep trackers causing
sleep issues so people be basically
become too obsessed with optimizing
maximizing scores and that alone will
actually it's actually you so you learn
when to wake up and so you have actually
uh an anticipatory response when many
hours prior to waking up so if you
actually learn to have a little bit of a
what's a little molecule of like
excitement and reward oh dopamine that's
the one if you start getting that
because you wake up and you get super
excited to check your score or your
phone it's the same thing if you check
your phone or Twitter or whatever
immediately morning that'll actually
start carving back your wake up time
because you start launching it so it can
ruin sleep becoming too obsessed so what
I'll say is if you're going to use a
sleep tracker
and you just like don't care you want to
check it and you have fun with it great
but if like you are really really
interested in it and you pay a lot of
attention to it don't check your sleep
score for at least the first 60 minutes
after waking up and then you'll that
should help you that's a great tool I
think that
um end piece of advice I think generally
because I think a lot of people are
waking up in the middle of the night
checking their phone two or three times
per night I'm kind of wondering why
they're doing that and I'm guessing it's
this anticipatory wake-up circuit yeah
you absolutely should use either your
night mode or do not disturb or airplane
mode or something overnight or leave it
out of the room yeah I mean if you have
to wake up and like some people have um
like a family member who's maybe not in
great health and so they have to get
their phone around in case they call or
things like that so I get it you're like
I can't leave it out leave it in there
leave it in do not disturb and enter in
their phone number or whoever's phone
number so only they can get through but
keep it black and white so if you do
have to look at your phone at night you
see black and white and you do not have
notifications so make sure that there's
no notification for no email and a no DM
like get all that stuff off your screen
and so you look at the did anybody call
did anybody text of importance
um what time is it no emergency going on
black and white okay right back to sleep
so that can help a little bit one of the
supplements that I found is extremely
useful for being able to fall back
asleep if I've woken up in the middle of
the night and for some reason can't
um and is also very effective for
enhancing sleep when one is ingesting
fewer carbohydrates an issue that a lot
of people run into or
for people that are fasting for many
hours before sleep you know people are
trying to not eat anything within you
know two to four hours but is inositol
900 milligrams of my myoinositol I I
find again this is anec data to be clear
that if I wake up in the middle of the
night and I've taken 900 milligrams of
inositol B4 initially falling asleep
that I fall back asleep much more easily
so that's why I've added 900 milligrams
of inositol to my so-called sleep stack
I've also tried just taking it alone and
it works well alone but it works better
of course with the mag 3 and 8 apogenic
themine sleep stack the um that also in
terms of tools for Sleep the the app
reverie that was developed by my
colleague Dr David Spiegel who's a
medical doctor at Stanford Psychiatry
Stanford School of Medicine Psychiatry
there is a free trial there's a nominal
cost if you use it
um month to month but the data are
really strong that people that use that
I think it's 8 to 11 minute sleep
hypnosis once a week and it doesn't have
to be in the middle of the night when
you wake up really helps improve
people's ability to fall asleep quickly
stay asleep fall back asleep if they
wake up in the middle of the night in
some cases curing insomnia in other
cases really just helping people with
their General sleep issues and I
mentioned this because obviously it's
the technology it's not a supplement but
I know that some people are supplement
diverse also if you look at by at the
cost comparison between taking the Sleep
stack totally
um and the reverie app it's Pennies on
the dollar really
um so again I'm a proponent of both for
myself but I realize that people have
varying budgets and again
I should say as always behavioral tools
first and I think of the reverie app as
more or less a behavioral tool yeah it's
uh it's really just a tool any of these
breath work protocols hypnosis protocols
they're just a tool for you to touch
back in with your own physiology rather
than a a substance that's coming in so I
fully support those we have used a
number of those
um in in protocols
there's some other tricks that we can
pull in those areas
um I probably shouldn't say this but the
real of it is depending on what's
keeping you up sometimes we recommend
just getting up and getting it done
like if it's a really like if it's a
a project or a thing or whatever like
sometimes it rather than laying there
all night not sleeping you can get up
get it done and then if you stay awake
fine at least the anxiety is gone
or sometimes you can actually go back to
sleep because you're like especially if
the task only literally would take like
10 or 15 minutes
um it may ruin your sleep but you're
you're going to have room sleep anyways
so you can try that tool um you don't
want to pull that card very often and
you have to have be very careful with
what you consider to be something Worthy
of doing that but that is like between
me and you and nobody else here that's a
tool I have used personally more than a
few times where it's just like
I get an idea I don't lose it or like
the solution for something you've been
noodling on for a long time Pops in your
head and just like and you're not
wanting to forget it just get up get it
done and
get on with your day
in several previous episodes you
emphasized how exercise induces various
adaptations depending on the type
specificity volume intensity Etc of the
exercise and that during exercise the
degree of adaptation that one triggers
is often associated with things that
normally we don't associate with
exercise related health things like
huge increases in blood pressure during
exercise huge increases in inflammatory
markers
muscle damage right these all things all
sound terrible but as you beautifully
explained all of that triggers
adaptations that then bring those
markers below the Baseline
with which they were previous to the
exercise so that's the adaptation in the
recovery within the Romo supplementation
of nutrition I'm aware of a number of
things
some herbal some lipid-based
other compounds that are used for
various things but that are known to
have a potent anti-inflammatory effect
things like
omega-3 fatty acids ashwagandha for its
effect on cortisol although that's a bit
indirect to the inflammatory pathway
um
curcumin and things of that sort given
that we want
inflammation in order to trigger the
adaptation response to exercise
and given that we want to reduce
inflammation in the recovery period can
we put together a logical framework as
to when is best to take anything
anti-inflammatory whether it's
supplement base or prescription or
over-the-counter drug and when to
strictly avoid taking any
anti-inflammatory supplement or
um a behavioral tool you mentioned ice
can reduce inflammation that's why you
don't want to do it too close to
exercise anyway I think you get the gist
of the question what about specific
supplements related to inflammation and
anti-inflammatory responses what are the
best ones when should we take them when
should we avoid taking them the way that
I think about it is understanding what
we call the fitness fatigue model so
what I mean by that is whenever you do
some sort of insult the whole idea is
for you to come back and get an
adaptation now recovery is not
adaptation right recovers recovery
adaptation is what happens after you're
recovered right so it's a very important
distinction there Fitness fatigue model
says basically you've done something and
you've got an adaptation and you've
enhanced Fitness
and by Fitness in this case I mean it as
a non-specific term so you got stronger
you've improved your endurance like
whatever thing you're trying to train
for at the same time though you're
fatigue elevated so what happens is if
Fitness increases at the same or similar
rate as fatigue your performance
actually isn't any better
and so you may think oh my program isn't
working I need to then train harder or I
need to take more anti-inflammatory or
whatever the things are when reality all
you really need to do is reduce fatigue
and if you do that your performance will
increase and all the training
adaptations will be actualized so the
way that we do that is a couple of
things first and foremost is actually a
taper
so the the first step I think of if
someone is training very very hard and
you're not seeing any results and we
want to think about supplementation
before I get there I want to think about
taper and deload if you're actually
training hard and sleep and everything
else is taken care of so just without
going too far into taper some general
General parameters there you want to
think about about a 50 reduction in
training volume
over the course of About a Week for
every eight weeks of training
super super rough right so if you've
been training hard for three months for
something
you might want to taper for two weeks
something like that right it's sort of a
rough estimate
that taper you actually don't need to
reduce intensity
because intensity is not the driver of
fatigue it tends to be volume so as long
as your volume is reduced by 50 you can
maintain intensity you can maintain in
fact I generally would recommend
maintaining frequency so if you're used
to working out four days a week keep it
four days a week you can go down a
little bit in frequency but if you go
down too much in frequency you actually
tend to feel super lethargic
so I wouldn't do that if you do those
things correctly
you can typically see somewhere between
like a three to eight percent
Improvement of performance
um within a matter of days so it's
important to do that um we actually ran
a study on cross-country Runners years
ago testing on a metabolic heart muscle
biopsies blood a whole bunch of things
and we did it pre and post three weeks
of taper and we actually this is cool
because we did this in competitive
season so these were Collegiate
cross-country Runners and we got them to
come to our lab three weeks before their
conference Championship ran them all
through a bunch of testing biopsied them
they went through their three-week taper
and then we biopsied them again and then
they went and ran
um their conference championships and
stuff well what happened was they end up
hitting about a 50 reduction because
what they did is they took out what we
call the junk volume so they kept their
race tempos high intensity stuff in
there they kept the recovery stuff and
then that Medium Pace they just
basically reduced now they were
terrified as any endurance Runner or
Dare it's athlete or participant would
understand when you take volume away
they tend to get very nervous and so
they didn't like like that but as a
result of that what we saw is their VO2
max despite the fact that they covered
half the mileage their VO2 max did not
go down in three weeks of reduced taper
your Fitness is is extremely stable and
in fact once we actually looked at their
data the enzymes in their muscle will be
responsible for oxidative metabolism
were maintained and so you don't have to
worry about losing uh Again Fitness
whether we're talking about overall
performance or even oxygen capacity
mitochondrial function
Etc that was all preserved
obviously we saw performance go up what
was actually really interesting is we
saw I think it was around a 10 percent
increase in type 2 which are fast twitch
muscle fiber size
so we saw a 10 percent increase in fast
food fiber size at the end of three
weeks of tapering
now what you may think is like wow I
guess tapering is anabolic but that's
probably not what happened what
realistically probably happened was
their volume of training
was actually causing their fibers to be
reduced in size and then once we removed
that fatigue they just recovered back to
normal
so that's a good example of what I'm
talking about once you remove the
fatigue you can actually see
enhancements in performance not because
you're necessarily getting better but
because you're removing the simulated
suppressing you so that being said
the way that you want to think about
recovery like this is although recovery
especially like injury recovery like
seems chaotic biology is very organized
and there's a very specific three-step
process that you're going to go through
for recovery and then there are
different supplements that can help you
in each of those three areas so area one
is basically inflammation so this is
when the cytokine storm comes rolling
out it starts signaling the injuries
there in this case even if it's muscle
damage and activates the immune system
to kick on and that whole repair process
happens there
um what you're trying to do effectively
in fact this is why you probably ever
wonder like why is inflammation a thing
and what you're trying to do is bring in
fluid enhance the size and increase
blood flow in so you can get nutrients
for repair and immune cells and
everything like that in the system and
get the waste out so short-term
inflammation even in the case of muscle
soreness is the example we we talked
about in the previous episode but any
inflammation it is part of the necessary
process that's why you would not want to
take an anti-inflammatory in that state
and so why you also would not want to do
things like an ice bath so in that
immediate inflammatory response time
window this is you know seconds to hours
after training you would want to stay
away from things like that
um a good option here are things like
Omega-3s good evidence something
somewhere in the neighborhood of like
two to five grams total
typically like a one-to-one EPA to DHA
ratio is fine similarly this is another
example of when good doesn't mean more
is better because for example there is
actually evidence showing up to 15 grams
will harm the immune response
and so you don't just want to be like
man I'm super sore I'm training harder
I'm just going to go to 10 grams a year
more and more you're actually causing
yourself more of a problem so
antioxidants anti-inflammatories are
fine again Omega-3s in that dosage are a
decent thing you can also do something
like 500 milligrams of curcumin three
times a day that's going to be enough to
keep you in a decent spot there are some
other things that you could look up
maybe some potential benefit for ginger
and baswellia and some things like that
for inflammation but
under unless we're in like very specific
circumstances where we have like an
injury we're probably not going to those
you know areas I just wanted to
highlight one thing that came up in a
previous episode some not all people but
some including myself are very sensitive
to curcumin yep it has a very potent
effect in reducing
DHT dihydro testosterone and leads to
all sorts of clamping of
testosterone-associated positive things
so
um I have experienced that myself I've
had people write to me and say I don't
understand I started taking a supplement
curcumin is supposed to be a great
anti-inflammatory it flatlined my libido
it took away my drive and kind of
wondering what's going on there those
people are very likely to be very DHT
sensitive curcumin while it's a potent
anti-inflammatory can also potently
reduce DHT but some people tolerate it
quite well and are hearing this and
probably think that's ridiculous well
it's certainly substantiated by the
biochemical Pathways that curcumin Taps
into in the known roles of DHT on libido
aggression power output Etc and mood so
just be wary that
um a there's no way to predict this one
simply has to figure it out empirically
meaning you have to try and see if you
like it or don't the good news is is
those negative effects on DHT can to
reverse pretty quickly after
ceasing to take curcumin so just a
mention of something that came up in a
previous episode but in case people
didn't hear that on that segment um just
wanted to highlight those those facts
further evidence do I I strongly
discourage
strongly discourage taking anything in
the anti-inflammatory antioxidant realm
unless you actually have a reason to do
so if you're waking up and you're like
maybe I'm inflamed that's probably not a
good approach right let's have a reason
to do so step two is actually what we
call proliferation and that's kind of
like the cleanup crew that's when you're
going to be going in there and cleaning
out dead cells and debris and misfolded
proteins and things like that at this
stage a fantastic evidence-based
supplement is glutamine glutamine 20
grams a day we typically honestly split
it up into two dosage 10 grams morning
10 grams a night it's a conditional
amino acid which means
you can make it your body can make
enough of it at times and other times
you may want to support it generally
those conditional times are things like
burn victims high stress situations or
injury things like that so there isn't
also like a ton of downside to glutamine
because it can go through transamination
which means your body can take it and
say like we don't need anything here for
our Muscle Recovery let's make it into
something else and use it
um
for whatever else is needing so it's
kind of another one of these like low
risk uh products is also why you see it
in a lot of recovery products if you're
ever wondering like what the heck is
that in there I don't need amino acids
and you're thinking it's like for
protein synthesis it's really not it's
because of this it is uh beneficial to
this proliferation process
I've been taking glutamine for years
um I tend to take it
in higher dosages several times
throughout the day if I remember feeling
particularly run down I know there are
decent data not great but decent data on
the role of glutamine for leaky gut
totally we're off saying leaky gut
that's getting a little bit into the
realm of uh like not super well
substantiated but in the in the
peer-reviewed literature but some a lot
of anecdata and um and certainly some
peer-reviewed work but not a ton and
then there is also growing interest in
the idea that glutamine
because it can trigger activation of the
neurons in the gut that signal to the
dopamine pathway in the brain that it
can be used to offset sugar Cravings
this is kind of an interesting new uh an
emerging theme which makes sense given
the biology of the neurons in the gut
that respond to specific amino acids
including glutamine essential fatty
acids and sugar and because they respond
to any uh and all three of those
anyone or
combination of those I should say to
trigger this dopamine response some
people have taken to a teaspoon or so of
gluten of glutamine in some water or
other drink a couple times throughout
the day as a way to reduce their sugar
Cravings because what it's essentially
doing is it's tricking the pathway into
into activation of those neurons through
an alternate ligand receptor interaction
right also another interesting point
there are very
I'm trying to think right now off the
top of my head I can't think of a time
and I've used glutamine a lot I can't
think of a time where I've ever heard
anybody come back with any side effect
reports I think if you take enough of it
you can get some gastric distress but of
course you take enough of any powdered
substance
mixed in water you're going to get a
gastric distress response and what I've
noticed about gastric distress with
things like creatine glutamine and even
protein powders for that matter I use a
high quality whey protein powder
routinely is that if you build up to it
over the course of a few days then you
can get away with using much higher
dosages without any issue yeah yeah um
beta alanine is the same thing by the
way we sort of talked about that earlier
if uh you've ever tried that and you're
like oh my gosh like I feel like I've
just rolled around in grass and my skin
is itching everywhere what's that ants
under the skin sensation yeah all that
stuff yeah you can just take a little
bit of a lower dosage and be fine but
for the most part and then you will
build up a tolerance to that pretty
quickly so you can up that dosage along
the way so what we will oftentimes do
there start at a dosage that's pretty
minimal like 2 grams and then every week
or so you can go up another gram until
you get to whatever final point you want
to be five six grams a day you know
whatever so that's another way you can
sort of mitigate that problem so the
third step in this recovery process
after inflammation proliferation we're
now into Remodeling and this is when
you're actually you know quote unquote
growing back bigger and stronger
um this is where the majority of the
repair is actually taking place and at
this point we're basically playing a
micronutrient and macronutrient game
right by that I mean we've talked about
basic macronutrients one thing to pay
attention to oftentimes if people are
hurt whether they had an injury or
they've had uh just they're super sore
and they are concerned about eating
excess calories
they tend to want to eat less food
during this process because they're like
I'm not working out so much so I'm gonna
eat less calories well one of the things
that you have to pay attention to is
injury can increase basal metabolic rate
by up to 10 percent wow so what you want
to do in general is just take your
calories up about 10 at least that's
what I recommend
um if that is an extended period of time
then yes you may put on a slight amount
of body fat or something but if that
also means you come back some percentage
faster then it's worth the exchange so
we recommend that in terms of your
carbohydrate or fat split I'm not super
worried about it my general
recommendation is just don't make any
major changes relative to what you were
doing right keep yourself pretty much in
the same spot
in terms of protein this is the big one
you want to make sure you're absolutely
at one gram per pound of body weight
because we need those amino acids to
come in and start helping with recovery
one gram of protein per pound of body
weight or more or one gram or more yeah
I mean there's gonna be very little
downside to having more
um
remember
protein
and carbohydrates both stimulate insulin
and remember insulin is anabolic and so
we're trying to drive this process of
recovery that's why you want both so you
wouldn't want to skimp on carbohydrates
in this phase nor would you want to
skimp on protein because you need the
activation the drive into the tissue as
well as the structure going back to one
of our earlier conversations and at this
point in the week I honestly can't
remember at all what episode we covered
this in but I gave an analogy about use
making a campfire and using fat and
carbohydrates is the wood and the log
and the protein were the the metal
structure so you need that Supply if
you're trying to bank if you've cleared
out in the previous step damaged
proteins and you need to make new ones
to recover that process you have to have
the raw Supply and material so you
wouldn't want to avoid either one of
those things there's actually some
indirect inflammation management that
comes from fatty acids which you
actually sort of alluded to earlier I
don't think you need to necessarily go
crazy you don't need to change your fat
intake that much just don't drop it you
know I depending on where you're at so
if you're a little bit of a higher carb
lower fat person great if you're
moderate great if you're the indirect if
you're higher fat lower carb person
awesome just don't make an extreme
change and don't and try to not be on
the extremes of either one of those
ratios but the only specific number to
pay attention to again is that protein
number and if you go a little bit high
or even a lot high it's totally fine
just don't go low
so that's the the macronutrient portion
of remodeling in terms of micronutrients
to be honest you just get your bases
covered this is when a basic
multivitamin is effective what you're
really trying to look at here are
vitamin A and zinc they actually have
independent mechanisms that are helpful
here but those are typically covered in
most multivitamins so we generally just
give people a multivitamin magnesium is
actually has some some benefits here
something like six milligrams per
kilogram of body weight is the dosage
you're looking for there
magnesium citrate is probably has the
most evidence in terms of this respect
but it doesn't mean I actually have no
reason to think you couldn't use
glycinate or if you're using another
form for sleep that's probably fine I
don't know that for sure but I can't
think of a reason why the other forms of
magnesium would all of a sudden not work
so you could probably choose whichever
form you like um albeit citrate has
probably the most research in this
aspect the only other things you would
probably consider here
three things calcium might be on your
list particularly if you're trying to if
you're concerned with some sort of bone
injury and we've sort of gone past like
recovering we're actually like into
injury so you'll see that in recovery
products occasionally and that's why and
then the last two ones of course are
vitamin D and that's pretty well
researched
and then the last one is actually uh
something that can help you if you're at
this stage
and you still are dealing with a lot of
soreness or not and that is tart cherry
juice and that's actually effective for
both Dom's muscle injury muscle soreness
and actually has another benefit of
potentially aiding with sleep so I'm not
a bad one to turn to as well there's a
number of companies that make these
things
um yeah and then there's actually more
ongoing research that I know of on those
areas but a promising literature we'll
say not often but every once in a while
on this podcast I will solicit social
media for questions from the audience
where I should say the audience to be
and then ask some of those questions on
the fly during the podcast I did this
with Dr Lex Friedman
I'm going to do it with you
your goal is to answer each of these
questions certainly not all of them
thousands of them within the last couple
of hours to answer each of these
questions
in three or four sentences I certainly
won't be counting the number of
sentences that you speak so just know
that if you want to go over a little bit
that's fine but feel free to refer to
your Instagram site at a future time
where you might go more in depth or to
refer to a study or um if you like you
can also say pass if you don't think
that you can answer the question
um succinctly enough for this format and
here the goal is not to put you on the
spot the goal is simply to allow the
audience to ask some questions directly
and I I confess I'm looking at these for
the first time so I'll try and be quick
with my with my reading
um some of these we may have touched on
in previous episodes or in this episode
even in which case you can just kind of
cue us to the reminder
this is not directly related to
supplementation but it is related to
nutrition and I don't think we touched
on this directly can we do intermittent
fasting AKA time restricted feeding with
keto and still gain muscle mass
TBD
the I am quite clear such study does not
exist so I don't know I think I've
alluded to before that we did run an
intermittent fasting 16-8 hypertrophy
study there was no keto arm the results
of that study by the time this comes out
we'll probably be ready though I'm not
sure so I can't comment on I haven't
looked at the data
but regarding whether or not if you did
that with keto or not I can't comment
scientifically
do you ever prescribe the use of Gaba
supplements
well I can't prescribe anything to make
sure we're clear but you're a professor
you can profess I can profess uh we
generally don't spend too much time on
Gaba rarely
is it okay to weight train fasted than
not
break the fast and eat for three or four
hours after training so in other words
train fasted I do this but then also not
eat immediately following training and
wait another three to four hours after
training once we have our results remind
fasting study back we will we will have
a better answer here my
General recommendation as it stands now
though is as long as your total protein
intake is sufficient you should be
in a decent spot
great a lot of questions about fasting
and training just to yeah to know that
um can you train high performance fasted
and how long before
um you need to refuel the body yeah you
can certainly do that I know of actually
many athletes some athletes that will do
that though the vast majority will not
as it gets higher and higher in
intensity and or duration it gets more
challenging but it really does come down
to what you did the day before as well
so if you ate sufficient calories a day
before didn't train and your glycogen
stores are topped off
you have a fighting chance now the
duration part of that equation is really
kind of dependent upon you
um so are you really talking 30 45
minutes 16 minutes you're probably fine
whether you're out past that in several
hours you may not be and then the only
other comment I would make is there is
keep in mind whenever you think about
fasting and any other let's say against
the textbook you know quote unquote
style you really really need to be
careful in thinking the difference
between can I do it and is it optimal so
I have absolutely no reason to think
fasting like that would improve
performance
I only work for the most part with
people who are trying to perform at the
highest level possible so I can't think
of a scenario which I would go too
fasting to try to enhance performance so
whether or not you can maintain some
level of performance probably will it
provide any benefit I struggle to find
scenarios in which that would actually
make you perform better
how do different forms of carbohydrates
impact performance and then right below
it another question about carbohydrates
which is does carbohydrate cycling work
so these are
two uh
questions from people that I think don't
know one another but a lot of questions
about carbohydrates and performance
which we've touched on anything else
that you want to add to that
conversation
I don't think I really maybe you might
want to think about carb loading uh
Slash carb cycling so carbohydrate
loading does help however a
misconception there is it's just you
know a big bowl of pasta the night
before
that can help top off storages but
really optimal carbohydrate loading
prior to a long duration endurance
performance is probably best over the
course of three or four days so you want
to gradually increase carbohydrate
intake for multiple days rather than
just have one big bowl of pasta
Branch chain amino acids and essential
amino acid supplementation yay nay or as
I would say meh uh meh usually if your
total protein intake is fine then you
don't really have a need for them
um if you're for whatever any number of
valid reasons total protein is not then
going to an essential amino acid would
be my first step rather than a BCAA now
admittedly we actually do use
essential amino acids somewhat regularly
because it's also sort of like a there's
no real harm other than if you're price
conscious and you're sort of like I'm
wasting money that's fine the people I
work with generally again that's not a
few dollars for
to maximize recoveries is not that very
so we will sometimes use that
pre-meter post training in some
circumstances uh total protein would be
my a high quality way something like
that
um if you can't use whey for whatever
reason there are plenty of high quality
vegan proteins you could use if you want
to top all that off though and add some
essential amino acids it wouldn't hurt
anything and may potentially help
slightly so you choose based on that
algorithm ah I was hoping somebody would
ask this I've touched on it a little bit
it's a little bit of a loaded question
the way they phrased it so um at risk of
leading the witness does the mythical
anabolic window really exist and I'm
just laughing because the way they posed
the question they're already telling us
what their stance is
um making it more effective as to create
hypertrophy to eat within a certain time
frame after working out I'm going to
assume that this person genuinely wants
to know whether or not the anabolic
window
really exists or not
um because they
refer to it as mythical I'm going to
assume that they're
um suspicious but what's the deal as the
anabolic window a real thing the
post-exercise anabolic window is
extremely real so what this is uh you
can see more detail in a number of
videos on my YouTube page I believe it
is the idea that you need to must
consume some sort of nutrients
specifically usually protein in the some
time domain 30 or 60 Minutes a post
exercise in order to maximize growth so
is that window real yes are you hyper
sensitized to nutrients in that time
frame yes is it very important that you
rehydrate replenish muscle glycogen and
rebuild tissue quickly after exercise to
maximize recovery absolutely
is not real though in the sense that you
that you have to have it within 30
minutes in the case of protein as we
talked about a second ago your total
protein intake throughout the day is
more important
timing though for things like
carbohydrate especially if you're
training multiple times a day it is very
real so it is a very real thing it's
just you may or may not actually care
about it it may not be important for
your context
garlic seems like an appropriate
question
what if any functional roles does garlic
have in performance Garlic's actually
really cool there's a number of things
you can dive into that are outside of my
three to four sentences considering I'm
at like two and a half probably already
um
you're not going to find strong human
data on garlic extract however there is
a little bit
suggesting it can actually enhance
recovery from injury or potentially
tissue damage so
you've got to kind of be careful though
because in order to understand what's
happening you have to differentiate
between innate an Adaptive recovery
processes
and when we say things like immunity
realize friends that's not one thing
that's just like a very colloquial term
for a number of things again it's a verb
like it's a noun right the immune system
but it immunity is a bunch of processes
or processes if you're about to correct
my speech I'll correct yours right back
um not yours Andy yeah listeners
processes tomato tomato
it's a verb immunity is a verb this is
my problem with immune boosters
same issue right you're like whoa what
are you boosting specifically because in
fact if you're boosting the wrong part
of unity
during the wrong phase of recovery with
garlic you may be actually hurting
in the process because you're
theoretically could be trying to down
regulate that portion so you can
upregulate a next portion that's the
faster way to say it if you will so
um we actually you may see more data
come out that says the garlic extracts
overrated
I don't know I actually don't even know
yet we just don't have enough human data
on it but yeah there's some stuff there
if you want to look hard enough
I'm going to ask this question for
myself
because I'm curious to know the answer
selfish tart cherry extract pretty
effective actually for two things uh
potentially aiding in sleep getting to
sleep as well as muscle soreness that's
the bulk of the research is in muscle
soreness and seems to be a moderate
effect there
I think for people that might be
interested in dosages of things like
tart cherry extract garlic Etc
um obviously Dr Andy galpin's Instagram
and Twitter are great places to ask
questions like that and to find
questions answers to questions like that
as well as examine.com as a terrific
website
um they actually recently overhauled
their entire website so they have this
human effect Matrix that shows the
um the effects and the the strength of
different effects in human studies of
many many different compounds
um relating to everything to you know
Hormone Health in men and women sports
performance cognitive performance it
doesn't cover everything but it
certainly covers a lot with links to
studies there's a lot that's available
at completely zero cost by joining
examine.com you can access some
additional features and this is by the
way not a paid endorsement from
examine.com I'm simply a long time user
of examine.com myself
um and so I just want a cue people to it
and again many of the resources there
are available completely free of costs
It's a Wonderful site so for dosages of
garlic tart cherry extract and things of
that sort whether or not you're getting
it from food or you're getting it from
extra powders rather
um all of that information is is pretty
nicely laid out there so unless you have
something to add to that I was just
going to cue people to that resource no
I've been using that since the first day
that website was launched I I was made
aware that it was coming I've been
fortunate to know those guys
for a while so yeah I've used it I've
used it in all my classes I use it I
don't even know probably weekly at this
point another nice feature that's
actually on there is they have a series
of
like they'll do some topical reviews
basically so they'll write a big paper
out on muscle damage or blood pressure
or testosterone testosterone enhancement
or
um hormone uh you know menstrual cycle
and and yeah PCOS I think they do one on
and all kinds of stuff so you can search
by topic uh like you know energy or
recovery or whatever or even search by
you know black cumin seed extractor like
whatever number of things you want to do
and they'll also tell you if there's any
interactions to pay attention to so it's
really really nice so be carefully if
you're taking a and b or whatever so
yeah it's wonderful wonderful yeah
they've done a marvelous job so thank
you examine.com keep keep up the amazing
work well we've come close to the end of
this episode and that means that we're
close to the end of this series where
you have so graciously joined us for six
full episodes of The huberman Lab
podcast to educate us on
all things Fitness
episode one
you reviewed and educated us on
assessing our level of Fitness in fact I
learned so many ways of assessing
Fitness that I had not thought about and
also assessing my recovery capacity for
instance one thing that I'm definitely
going to implement from that episode is
a routine broad jump test and uh an
in-home high jump jump and touch test if
people don't know what I'm referring to
that's all contained in that episode
It's Time stamped these are very
straightforward zero cost ways to assess
one's level of Fitness there are a few
others that require a bare minimum of
Technology like taking your pulse rate
in very specific ways at specific times
also some timing of mile runs and some
other things relate to strength and
hypertrophy and on and on really it's a
it's a buffet of options that we can
select from and I already know the four
or five that I've started implementing
this week I've recognized how I'm pretty
good in a couple of areas
I'm doing maybe maybe better than pretty
well in one area but that I'm doing a
abysmally poorly in a few areas that um
I just wasn't aware of and so I've
already started
um taking on ways to uh adjust that over
time and I'll keep people posted so that
first episode was absolutely incredible
and just provides so much actionable
knowledge and the rationale behind it
the second episode you educated us about
strength speed and hypertrophy training
and there too an immense amount of
incredible knowledge
we got way down into the details you
explained sets reps the rationale for
sets reps rest cadence number of
workouts per week
I'm definitely going to take away my
need to do some speed Based training and
some power Based training normally I
think in terms of strength or
hypertrophy
and I'm relieved to learn that a lot of
the speed and power Based training is
low intensity enough that it can be done
fairly often and incorporated into my
program which already touches on
strength and hypertrophy and indeed some
endurance work as well so amazing tips
that you provided there I'm certainly
going to implement the three to five
program that you describe three to five
exercises done for three to five
repetitions
three to five minutes
between sets uh you're doing this three
to five times per week and so on and so
forth all the details again time stamped
um in the strength and hypertrophy uh
episode show note so just incredible we
even use that to set up PR with you this
week that's right I did PR this week
thanks thanks to your input and
following that program and um I'm really
grateful for that it does feel good to
break through a barrier
um and I intend to break through more
barriers but not just with strength and
hypertrophy because episode three you
taught us all about endurance
the four different forms of endurance
how to train for each of those different
forms the value of doing even very brief
22nd
Sprints or bouts of jumping jacks
throughout the day which to some people
might just sound like a you know like a
little hack or a gimmick but no these
are actually tapping into fuel systems
and modes of neuromuscular interactions
that greatly Aid other forms of
endurance like long duration endurance
I would love to return to my
um High School mile time I won't reveal
what that is because this is not really
about me but I plan to start doing
um if not mile repeats than doing some
mile mile runs and testing there once a
week
you laid out a beautiful program for how
to do that and then in the next episode
you
wowed us again with a description of the
science and the tools and this right
down to the details but all laid out
very cleanly and clearly as to how to
design an optimal fitness program what
are the things that really represent an
optimal program what questions does one
have to answer before designing a
program what are some of the barriers in
the way this concept of Defenders as
things that prevent you from reaching
your goals and one of the key things I
have it right here in front of me that I
took away from that episode is was this
quadrant
approach of really thinking about and
figuring out how much one intends to
devote to work career calling let's make
that one bin relationships
another been Fitness in the other bin
and Recovery in the other bin and um
here we'll tip our hat to our good
friend Kenny Kane
um for
um mentioning that overall
um scheme for doing things it's been
immensely useful and I've actually
charted it out and thought about and
drawn out which Different Things fall
into each of these categories you might
think it's obvious okay relationships
but that includes a lot of different
things and there's crossover between
these bins
um in terms of how you can combine
enhancing relationships with Fitness
work recovery and so on so that episode
is just again a treasure Trove of
knowledge and then in the next episode
you you educated us on recovery in all
its forms in the very short term in
within the workout immediately after the
workout and from workout to workout ways
to really accelerate recovery assess
recovery and as you pointed out for
people like me who always assume that we
don't recover very well and that some
sort of character trait or nervous
system thing or genetic to really think
about how my training is impacting my
level of recovery and in doing so is
revealed to me that I have far more
capacity than I thought I had and
already this week I've managed to train
more often
doing more work and I feel better than
ever
um and that's also despite the fact that
we've spent a fair amount of time in
these chairs across from one another
it's a kind way to say it well it's it's
been it's been a pleasure and then in
today's episode you explained nutrition
and supplementation as it relates to
Performance and of course that touches
into recovery but also optimal mental
States for training how to approach
one's training and how to extract the
most from training through quality
nutrition right so what to eat and when
which carbohydrates protein amounts
Windows of opportunity Windows you
absolutely don't want to miss and then
some that are a bit more flexible and
then we went
deep into the weeds of magnesium garlic
tart cherry extract Alpha GPC we touched
on neural transmitter related systems
hormone-related systems
we went deep into a discussion about
sleep because of course sleep is the
foundation for recovery and performance
of all kinds emotional mental and
physical recovery and performance
and in taking us through this enormous
Arc of a journey through Fitness
I think it's fair to say that you've
given us your knowledge contained in
your head I was telling someone just the
other day that one of the things that I
always lamented in science is that I
would encounter these incredible
professors and scientists and in other
domains of life too and you just wish
there was some way to download their
brain because they had so much knowledge
inside them and um I'm looking for a USB
or USBC port on you and I don't see one
yet but what you've effectively done for
us across these six episodes is to
download the actionable knowledge and
you know it's wonderful the information
you've provided is clear
it's super interesting it's highly
highly actionable and in many cases it's
counterintuitive and surprising but once
one understands the logic behind it as
you've provided for us also then it all
makes sense in a way that's extremely
satisfying and extremely motivating so
it's certainly motivating me to change
the way that I train in a number of ways
and I promise that I'll report back to
our audience and to you as to what my
results are but really
as we both agree this is not about me
this is not about you this is really
about the people listening and so for
those of you listening I hope you can
appreciate what an Incredible Gift it is
to have somebody of Dr Andy galpin's
experience and
um drive and uh scholarly background who
also works with athletes and everyday
people just to splay out all this
knowledge for us systematically over six
episodes
Dr Andy Galpin thank you ever so much I
appreciate that far too kind of uh words
to me there if you've been following
along through this entire Journey as you
called it you know I like first
principles thinking and I like lists so
I'm gonna get you with one more list and
I got five things on this final list get
your pen and Pat out please number one I
want to really emphasize
science itself is a verb which means
it's ongoing and changing I I did my
best
over the course of these many many many
hours to provide my interpretation of
the science
to provide my practical knowledge and
things that I use but that's fallible
science changes there are many many
things in my career that I was very sure
the uh that the evidence was clear on
and then it changed so as you move
forward do not think of any of the
recommendations I gave you whether they
were about supplement dosages and timing
rep ranges or breathing tactics anything
in between
just use them as guidelines so
number one science is a verb
number two
I really want to thank the audience this
has been an extremely long haul as some
of you have somehow I'm sure which I'm
not sure how but some of you have
probably made it through this entire
journey and listened to all six episodes
and you should probably get some sort of
free huberman lab shirt or something or
a plaque or I don't know how about a
galp in plaque ah I got from black how
about a internet high five and even if
you just dropped in for a few of the
episodes uh you know I appreciate you
taking the time there's a lot of things
you could be doing with your time and to
make to spend those resources on my
words is touching
number three
uh I want to actually thank you of
course Andrew and the whole team and the
crew up here for three things number one
um I think it's incredibly important
that you have gone out of your way to
give other people credit for their work
you go out of your way on your large
platforms and social media to tag people
to give scientists credit for their work
and most people do not do that and
that's something you don't have to do
and I think that is a culture you know I
know why you do it you come from science
that's just what you do you give people
credit for their work but you go out of
your way to do that and so I want to
thank you for that
the next one is
many people who have
outlets and platforms will try to fill
those with people who are going to grow
their platforms it doesn't mean these
people are wrong or bad but I think
what's extremely special about what
you've created here is again you have
gone out of your way to bring on the
direct source of information I can't
even imagine how many of your podcasts
guests have never been on a podcast
before
or have been on a very short number of
them and you've made an extremely large
platform doing nothing but talking about
super deep dork science directly from
the scientists themselves and to create
a community like that it's
um I'm so happy that science is is made
it here and you've shown the world
um people aren't stupid people want
detail and people want science and
you've given it them
um
the last one of course let's see if I
get through this is uh
thank you for what you've done for me in
my career I
understand there could have been any
number of people in this chair
to put me on your platform once was
um incredibly gracious
but to do it for 600 hours or whatever
we did in this series is uh
um I can't thank you enough for that
opportunity so I hope I lived up to it
and I had a tremendous time and then
thank you for being such a gracious host
well you more than exceeded uh
expectations you are absolutely the
person to be in this chair talking about
these topics
with me and for the world
and
like once again I just want to say thank
you
as a colleague as a public educator as
an exercise scientist and as a friend
if you're learning from and or enjoying
this podcast please subscribe to our
YouTube channel that's a terrific zero
cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a
five-star review if you have questions
for us or comments or suggestions about
topics you'd like us to cover or guess
you'd like me to include on the huberman
Lab podcast please put those in the
comments section on YouTube we do read
all the comments please also check out
the sponsors mentioned at the beginning
and during today's episode that's the
best way to support this podcast I'd
also like to inform you about the
huberman Lab podcast free newsletter
it's called the neural network
newsletter and each month the neural
network newsletter is sent out and it
contains summaries of podcast episodes
specific protocols discussed on the
human Lab podcast all in Fairly concise
format and all completely zero cost you
can sign up for the neural network
newsletter by going to hubermanlab.com
go to the menu and click on newsletter
you provide us your email we do not
share it with anybody and as I mentioned
before it's completely zero cost by
going to huberman lab com you can also
go into the menu tab and go to
newsletter and see some example
newsletters from months past thank you
once again for joining me for today's
discussion about fitness exercise and
performance with Dr Andy Galpin and as
always thank you for your interest in
science
[Music]